[Musique]
Alexis Rousell, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes dans
les conditions du direct. Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
? Oui, je suis Alexis Rousell. Je suis
l'auteur d'un livre qui s'appelle Notre
si précieuse intégrité numérique. Euh je
suis juriste et j'ai travaillé d'abord
aux Nations Unies pendant quelques
années. Et puis maintenant je suis dans
euh je suis directeur des opérations
d'une entreprise qui s'appelle NIM
Technologies et qui construit un mixnet
et on parlera sûrement de ce que c'est
un mixnet.
Donc, on a choisi de vous interviewer
aujourd'hui pour des raisons d'intégrité
mentale, d'intégrité numérique, de
respect de la vie prier, de comment
combattre les gens qui vous trace,
pourquoi ils vous tracent, quelles sont
les professions à risque et quelles sont
les répercussions pour la démocratie.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire des
risques de la collecte de données, du
non chiffrement des données, du
comportement invasif de certaines
sociétés et de certains gouvernements et
des risques pour la démocratie ?
Le risque, il est assez simple parce
qu'en fait la la quantité de données
qu'on collecte maintenant sur les gens
est juste
énorme. Elle permet en fait finalement,
sans que la personne le sache,
d'identifier un individu à travers des
bah la population tire, à travers des
milliards avec je crois peut-être une
soixantaine ou 80 points de de mesures
différents et aujourd'hui on a des
millions de points de mesure qui sont
disséminés à travers notre connexion
internet, à travers notre téléphone, à
travers tout enfin euh et votre
démarche, votre façon de scroller, votre
façon de bouger, votre souris, c'est des
choses que on n' pas l'impression
pression qu'on est en train d'émettre.
Mais en fait, on aimait constamment le
fait que on se réveille le matin et on
prend son téléphone. C'est des données
quand on va aux toilettes et qu'on
regarde encore son
téléphone, ça quand on passe à son
ordinateur, ça montre connectée.
même les même les la captation en dehors
de de nous-même, c'est-à-dire les
caméras dans la rue, les gens qu'on
croise lorsque l'on lorsque l'on marche
dans on rentre dans les magasins, les
paiements que l'on fait, enfin voilà,
tout tout ça, ce sont des données qui
sont constamment générées et collectées
sur nous et qui rentrent dans des dans
des milliards d'algorithmes différents
qui sont capturés par des sociétés de
publicité par des sociétés de sécurité,
par des États. Il y a comme ça un am de
données qui est qui est traité et
derrière ça, il y a un marché de ces
données. Ces données sont constamment
traitées,
revendues. Il y a aussi une partie de de
captation publique et en fait qui sont
liées entre eux. euh ce qu'on appelle le
le le capitalisme de surveillance ou le
ou le aussi le capitalisme de connivance
où en fait les les tout le secteur
privé, le secteur public collabore en
fait dans ce traitement gigantesque de
données et là-dedans, il y a des gens
qui vont euh soit pour de la publicité
tout simplement, mais aussi pour des des
des raisons autres vont en fait profiter
de ces algorithmes pour renvoyer de
l'information vers les gens. euh
pour initier un un comportement d'achat
par exemple euh ou pour initier un
comportement euh politique ou changer
une une compréhension de la de la vie
que qu'on peut avoir. Et euh et en fait
cette cette ce la partie la plus
importante à comprendre, c'est que
l'individu n'a pas la capacité à
comprendre la taille de ce qui est en
train de se passer, hein. même moi qui
arrive à décrire en quelque mot ce qui
se passe, qui peut peut-être on peut
peut-être mesurer en terabyte de données
ou en je sais
pas oui en terbyte de données, on peut
mesurer physiquement comment ce ce monde
se crée, mais en réalité c'est au-delà
de notre capacité individuelle à
s'imaginer l'impact que ça a et on a
l'impression qu'on est toujours autonome
et qu'on est toujours libre de ses
choix. Mais en fait cette machine là,
elle vient nous cette machine qui est
construite par la société vient
obligatoirement changer notre notre
manière de penser. qui dit manière de
penser euh dit bah que notre capacité à
prendre des décisions est différente et
donc forcément obligatoirement c'est un
impact sur notre démocratie parce que la
démocratie doit pour fonctionner
garantir que les citoyens soient libres
et soient autonomes et soient capables
de prendre leur décision par eux-mêmes
en leur amé conscience en leur amé
conscience exactement et justement le le
rapport de force entre le citoyen et
l'État démocratique
L'État démocratique doit respecter cette
autonomie, doit respecter cette
intégrité physique, mentale. Euh et moi
je même je dis qu'elle doit le respecter
de façon aussi numérique. Pour et je
vais donner un exemple tout simple, tout
bête, enfin un truc un peu cach. Si tu
vas à si tu rentres dans une mairie pour
aller
voter, imagine que tu es un garde à
l'entrée de la mairie et puis que alors
petite précision, tu es ? Alors moi je
suis SU, Oui, on vote on vote nous très
régulièrement. Mais mais là l'exemple
que je vais donner, il est il est il est
universel, on va dire. Euh tu rentres
dans une mairie pour aller voter et puis
en France ou en Suisse, le système il
est assez simple. Tu rentres dans la
mairie, tu votes, tu t'enregistres.
Enfin voilà. Euh, imagine que tu es un
garde à l'entrée qui euh tape
systématiquement les gens qui vont qui
vont rentrer. Euh, donc euh qui oui,
taper avec un bâton tout simplement et
qui va atteindre à l'intégrité physique
de la personne. Est-ce que tu penses que
tu vas voter de la même manière si tu es
tapé ou si tu es pas tapé ? Hein ? Non,
tu vas pas voter de la même manière en
étant tapé. il y a il y a il y a
quelqu'un qui il y a une forme
d'autorité qui est là et qui va te
t'inciter à à
à penser ou ne pas aller voter ou ainsi
de suite. Donc le là c'est beaucoup plus
subtile parce qu'en fait ce flow
d'information qui est qui est qui
revient vers toi et qui est qui qui est
qui est construit sur ce que toi tu es
constamment, ce flot d'information vient
subtilement des fois pour des bonnes
raisons, pour te t'offrir un super
service pour te permettre d'écouter la
musique que tu aimes bien ou ainsi de
suite vient t'influencer mais en en même
temps ça modifie en fait ta capacité de
prendre décision et aujourd'hui les
démocraties
actuelles sont pas adaptés à ça. Autant
on avait construit justement des des
cadres, des gardes fous pour éviter que
bah justement il y a un policier qui te
tape à l'entrée de la mairie, on sait
que c'est pas bien. Donc on le fait ou
ou quelqu'un qui t'offre un billet ou
d'ofre quelqu'un qui t'offre un billet.
Voilà. Donc on a dans la démocratie
traditionnelle, on va dire de l'ère
industrielle, on a développé
suffisamment de de d'outils et de
compréhension pour minimiser en fait ces
risques là et s'assurer que la
population dans son ensemble a la
capacité de prendre des décisions par
elle-même. Mais dans le numérique, tout
ce travail-là n'a pas été fait. Faisons
une expérience de pensée ensemble. H euh
comme tu le sais, comme vous le savez,
on aime bien faire de l'anticipation de
la prospective et on a différents
différentes sondes qui nous indique
quelles sont les grandes tendances qui
vont presser nos démocraties ou
influencer sur nos démocraties comme la
géopolitique, l'énergie et tout un tas
d'autres facteurs qui peuvent mettre la
population en stress ou l'économie en
stress ou le le biotop en stress.
Faisons une expérience de pensée. À
l'heure actuelle, les économies
européennes voire occidentales
rencontent un dilemme cornélien entre la
pression des ressources, la stabilité de
la monnaie, les pressions
géopolitiques. Quand on a des lames de
rasoir numérique tell que tu nous as tu
nous les as
décrites, s'il y a un basculement
démocratique vers des gouvernement
autoritaires, est-ce qu'on a
pas on fait pas l'erreur de leur laisser
des lames de rasoir pouvant influencer à
grande échelle nos démocraties ? Et
quels sont les outils qui pourraient
permettre de limiter ces lames de rasoir
sur nos esprits, nos cerveaux, sur nos
âmes, sur nos cœurs, sur nos perception,
sur notre moi profond qui
permettent de faire société, de trouver
des consensus et d'être dans une société
pacifiée. Si les
démocraties switchent en gouvernement
autoritaire, c'est l'âme de rasoir,
quels peuvent être leur impact ? Essaie
de me décrire ces impacts là en cas
concret.
Moi, moi je pense que ça va se faire
d'abord.
Euh ça va se faire parce qu'on on voit
déjà que en Europe le le le mouvement il
est il est lancé vers cela et c'est pas
faute de l'avoir prédit hein.
C'est-à-dire que dans dans nos milieux
depuis depuis la mise en place des des
de la surveillance dans les années 80
90, on a toujours dit attention c'est
escalade. On parlait des des caméras de
vidéosurveillance qui ne servaient à
rien et qu'on pourtant on continue à
rajouter et puis et et on voit
que et on disait à l'époque
attention ça va être abusé et puis la
réponse en face c'était oui mais on est
une démocratie on sait gérer ça
faites-nous
confiance il y a des gardes de fou et
tout ça mais vous mettez en place une
infrastructure qui peut être utilisée du
jour au lendemain par un un mouvement un
mouvement autoritaire enfin un
gouvernement autoritaire et aujourd'hui
on commence à les voir apparaître.
Voilà. Euh et donc les abus les abus ils
vont se faire et puis les abus ils sont
il ça va être ça va être assez simple
hein parce qu'on on voit déjà la manière
dont ça a été fait euh en Russie par
exemple qui est un très bon exemple ou
le le le ou en Chine. Euh je prends
l'exemple de la Russie parce que là là
j'ai j'ai des exemples assez assez assez
concrets. enfin la la la Chine aussi,
mais la manière dont l'opposition a été
supprimée euh euh tout simplement par
exemple avec l'installation des vidéos
vidéos de surveillance avec
reconnaissance faciale dans la rue. Et
en fait, ils avant même que une
manifestation se se faisait, dès queil y
avait des certaines personnes qui
sortaient de chez eux, ils étaient
attrapés et donc placés 24 heures au
trou puis relâcher. Et l'idée c'est que
ça ça tue dans l'œuf en fait n'importe
quelle forme de contestation, n'importe
n'importe quelle forme de
de d'opposition et et ça a un effet le
le mécanismes sur un effet en plus qui
est moi des fois j'aime bien dire c'est
c'est un effet un peu comme la la dans
la physique antique quand tu observes
quelque chose en fait ça modifie le
le l'objet en lui-même. Voilà. Et donc
en fait quand tu quand tu as une
population et que tu mets en place un
système de surveillance, forcément le
comportement de la population va changer
parce qu'elle sait qu'elle est euh
qu'elle est euh elle est surveillée et
donc elle va prendre naturellement un
comportement docile qui va être abusé
par le le le gouvernement autoritaire.
Euh et
euh et c'est c'est assez simple parce
qu'après on rentre en plus avec les
algorithmes dans une recherche et les
autres les les les gouvernements
autoritaires vont faire ça dans une
recherche d'efficacité dans la recherche
de la sécurité et donc on va aller vers
une automatisation euh qu'on est déjà en
train de faire hein, une une
automatisation des des amendes de la
justice et on va avoir une
automatisation de la de la répression
qui va arriver derrière. Donc euh
compris en terme prédictif par exemple
terme et et en terme prédictif. Et
pourtant, les expériences aux États-Unis
sont
catastrophiques. On a ils ont mis en
place des systèmes prédictifs qui leur
leur faisait que la police arrêtait tous
les tous les noirs du du quartier parce
que elle se construisait sur des sur des
bases de données où il y avait un peu
plus de noir qui était des délinquants.
Et donc le système en fait a a a forcé
les policiers à aller dans les quartiers
noirs et à arrêter encore plus de monde.
Donc c'était c'était vraiment une une
catastrophe. Et au lieu de dire bah on
arrête, c'était une erreur, bah
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils ont dit
"Ah, on va corriger pour faire mieux."
Et et finalement aujourd'hui, ces outils
ils restent là. Pour se pour se
protéger, enfin l'impact sur la société,
c'est
que toute forme d'opposition va va
disparaître. Et le le rôle d'une
démocratie, c'est de garder une tension
constante entre les institutions et les
citoyens qui doivent avoir qui doivent
constamment être en en méfiance de ce de
ce de en méfiance et qui doivent oui
observer tout constamment ces
démocraties pour les pour créer une un
équilibre des pouvoirs et ça ça va ça
c'est en train de disparaître. On nous
on nous enlève cette possibilité de le
faire. comment se protéger de ça ?
parce queen fait on ça vient aussi
modifier les discussions, c'est-à-dire
que on essaie d'avoir des discussions
sur un certain nombre de sujets et en
fait l'environnement ambiant autour de
nous va nous pousser à avoir des
discussions sur d'autres choses. les les
vrais sujets les vrais sujets de
transformation de la société
aujourd'hui, ils sont pas discutés ni en
France
ni ni en
Suisse sur justement comment est-ce que
cette parce que le pour moi le fond le
fondamental de la de la transformation
qu'on est en train de vivre, c'est mon
opinion, mais on vient de changer d'air.
On est passé d'une are industrielle à
une aire du numérique. Cette are du
numérique, elle est caractérisée par le
fait que nos relations interpersonnelles
passent aujourd'hui par des outils
numériques et ça modifie en fait
finalement la manière dont la société
discute. Et donc toutes les structures
de pouvoir sont perturbées par cela
parce que les mécanismes de gouvernance
qu'on avait avant étaient liés au fait
que ça prenait du temps d'aller discuter
avec une autre personne à travers un
pays. Il fallait se déplacer.
Aujourd'hui, on peut discuter avec tout
le monde de façon paire à paire à
travers la planète. Ça modifie
fondamentalement la société et donc ça
va appeler à modifier la gouvernance. Et
les les les institutions d'aujourd'hui
sont pas adaptées à ça. Elles ont peur.
Elles elles elles elles ne maîtrisent,
elles ne comprennent pas ce qui est en
train de se passer. Donc qu'est-ce
qu'elles font ? fige le le le le le
débat dans les débats qu'elle que elle
comprend euh et les débats qui sont lié
à comment est-ce qu'on va redéfinir les
pouvoirs au niveau local, comment est-ce
qu'on redéfinit les pouvoirs dans des
pays dans un cadre d'une société
informatique ? Eux, ils sont ils sont
pas discutés.
J'aimerais qu'on fasse ensemble qu'on
prenne la position de l'avocat du diable
et j'aimerais que tu défendes pendant 2
minutes la société de surveillance à la
sauce 1984.
Euh pourquoi faire ça ? Pourquoi faire
ça ? Mais c'est pour c'est pour ta
sécurité. C'est pour ta sécurité. Et et
puis pour une pour une société à risque
zéro, on aimerait vivre dans une société
où il peut jamais rien t'arriver de mal.
une société
où ton chemin va être tu auras dans
toute ta vie, tu auras jamais aucun
souci, tu auras toujours à manger, tu
auras
toujours un travail, toujours tu auras
toujours en fait
finalement
euh une une vie qui était qui était
toute tracée. Euh tu seras protégé des
risques terroristes, tu seras protégé de
tout, des ingérances extérieures, mais
même aussi de la santé. tu vas vivre
très longtemps. Euh tu vas vivre 150 ans
parce que tu auras ta montre qui va
t'expliquer tout ce qu'il faut faire.
Euh ça va une société où on te donnera
le
le la joie qu'il faut grâce à des à de
la à la de la dopamine qui te sera
injectée d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Euh ce sera une vie ce sera une vie
fabuleuse. Euh mais en réalité alors là
je sors de ça fait 25 secondes. 25
secondes. Je dois faire 2 minutes comme
ça. C'est difficile. C'est très
difficile. Moi je non, je je moi je
comprends que en fait la la Est-ce que
tu peux comprendre aussi le stress des
gouvernants qui voit une société qui est
de plus en plus vaste, de plus en plus
intriquée, avec des risques de plus en
plus forts et ce côté
fébrile du calme social avec des
puissances étrangères qui deviennent de
plus en plus agressifs avec une guerre
économique de plus en plus agressive où
ils en viennent à coloniser nos esprits
pour pousser
leur leur dialectique, leur rhthorique
et et leur
but. Je me mets à la place du président
Macron de et de notre
ministre
bien-aimé de l'intérieur et et il est
exposé à des attentats terroristes. Il
les il est il est exposé à des
des factions agressives. Euh il est
exposé à du renseignement économique sur
nos boîtes et il pense bien faire.
Qu'est-ce que tu pourrais lui dire pour
lui dire peut-être tu te trompes de
route et le chemin que tu es en train de
tracer va supprimer toute humanité ?
Euh ça c'est une sacrée question. Tu
crois que tu es venu pour pousser un cad
ou quoi ?
Euh euh qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je
peux lui qu'est-ce que je peux lui dire
?
Euh le euh j'aimerais que tu rebondisses
aussi sur pousser un cad la modélisation
des gens dans les supermarchés. Allez,
je j'arrête de t'ennuyer. Euh non, le le
le en fait le moi ce que j'observe c'est
et et comme tu l'as dit, je suis en
Suisse et et en Suisse, on a cette
chance d'avoir cette très vieille
démocratie directe, participative et qui
se fait même au niveau des des communes,
hein. Et en fait, moi ce que j'ai envie
de de lui dire, c'est la la sa chose
suivante. Je vois que la Suisse, on est
capable de discuter des enjeux du
numérique d'une autre manière que en
France. En France, le débat il est il
est il est complètement abs débat est
absent en fait de de cette
transformation numérique, elle est
absente du débat absente ou absconne
abscon, pardon.
Moi, je pense qu'elle est je pense
qu'elle est enfin je la vois juste pas.
Enfin, je dirais absent. Moi, je dirais
absent. Euh en Suisse, on a ce on a ce
débat-là qui euh qui est qui existe.
Alors, c'est des débats euh des fois
très simples, hein, genre mais j'aime
les les personnes âgées à Azuric
voudrait garder le ticket papier pour
aller euh pour utiliser le tram euh
localement. Voilà, ils veulent pas être
obligés d'utiliser leur leur app. C'est
des c'est des débats comme ça. Mais ce
que j'ai remarqué, c'est que euh
fondamentalement euh euh en Suisse, ce
débat est possible parce que le principe
de subsidiarité au sein de la société,
il est du bas vers le haut, hein. Euh ça
veut dire quoi ? Ça veut dire que euh
dans une démocratie normale, le peuple
donne le pouvoir à l'État, mais l'État
ensuite se structure. Et il y a deux
manières de structurer. La manière
française, la manière suisse. La manière
française, c'est quoi ? L'État dans la
le peuple dans la Constitution donne
pouvoir à l'État. L'État, c'est euh les
institutions euh président, assemblée et
autres 5 de la 5e République. Et ensuite
le pouvoir descend, il est délégué vers
les échons inférieurs, vers les régions,
vers les départements et vers les
communes. Et euh et en bas, on a des
gens qui sont au qui représentent les
autorités qui sont au contact de la de
la population, mais qui en fait ont une
structure de pouvoir. C'est c'est là où
les frictions réelles de la société se
font. C'est là où les gens parlent de
ces de ces changements là ou vivent en
tout cas ou ressentent ces changements
là. Et lorsque ils
doivent prendre des décisions, en fait,
il faut faire
remonter le problème, la problématique
en haut. En Suisse, c'est l'inverse.
C'est le le la nationalité de la quand
tu deviens si si tu acquieres ta
nationalité en Suisse, tu l'acquieres à
travers la commune. C'est la commune qui
te donne de la ta nationalité, tes
voisins. Euh tes voisins, enfin c'est la
commission du du village où tu es qui te
donne ta nationalité. Et ce qui veut
dire que le rapport de subsidiarité dans
dans la structure, il est du bas vers le
haut. C'est-à-dire que ce sont les
communes qui se sont mis ensemble qui
créent des cantons et les cantons en
fait ensemble créent un état fédéral et
tu as des négociations qui se
font euh euh entre à chaque niveau. Et
surtout le le le lien en fait entre le
citoyen et la communauté légale le
locale, c'est là où se règlent les
choses et les gens ils ont les moyens.
Et ça se voit dans des trucs très
triviaux, c'est que ça se voit dans tes
impôts. Euh quand tu payes tes infos, tu
dois payer deux, tu as deux bulletins de
versement à à payer à la fin de l'année.
Un vers l'état fédéral, un vers les
autorités locales. Et les autorités
locales, c'est 80 % de tes impôts. Et
donc les Suisses, ils comprennent très
bien que la puissance économique, elle
est au niveau des cantons, du local. Euh
et euh et c'est ça que je dirais euh au
euh c'est ça que je dirais à à un
ministre par exemple euh ou à un
président, c'est que dans une are
numérique où justement euh euh qui est
mondialisé euh les gens perdent la
connexion avec
euh le le l'énorme état qui est
au-dessus d'eux parce que même à l'état
même à l'échelle de la France, un état
de 60 millions de personnes, c'est déjà
gigantesque pour un individu de
d'appréhender la chose et quand toutes
les décisions vont se prendre en en haut
et ben elles vont être forcément prises
par algorithme et on va essayer de de
euh elles vont elles vont être elles
vont être captées par ce cette énorme
machine euh
algorithmique. Euh et pour revenir et et
donc il y a une perte de de voilà une
perte de de croyance dans ce système-
là, une perte de de de connexion avec la
la réalité pour les gens. Euh et le fait
de renverser le principe de
subsidiarité, c'est une réponse, mais
c'est une révolution énorme pour la
France parce que la France est construit
sur ce sur ce sur cette pyramide de
pouvoir qui est vers le haut. Toi qui a
étudié euh toutes ces atteintes à notre
intégrité mentale,
numérique, pratiquement législative pour
t'emmener dans un chemin que peut-être
tu n'aurais pas choisi si tu avais ton
intégrité de de pensée en ton âme et
conscience.
Est-ce que tu n'as pas l'impression de
voir au sein de la population française
et peut-être suisse des somnambules par
rapport au rat de maré cette menace qui
est complètement incomprise. Est-ce que
tu as l'impression que nos
intellectuels, vos
intellectuels sensibilisent correctement
le le la population à ses menaces ou
est-ce que tu as plutôt l'impression que
la population n'a plus envie de s'y
intéresser et devient somnambule ? Alors
euh je pense pas qu'elle ait pas envie
de s'intéresser à ce sujet. Pourquoi ?
Parce que quand en Suisse on a on a
travaillé, j'ai travaillé sur un concept
qui est le droit à l'intégrité
numérique. Et ce droit à l'intégrité
numérique il il se il se découle en fait
avec des on va dire des sous-droits
comme le droit le droit à la vie hors
ligne, donc le droit de choisir si je
suis connecté ou pas connecté pour faire
tes impôts, pas tes impôts ? Non, pour
faire tes impôts électroniquement ou à
en papier et déposer ça au au bureau de
au bureau des impôts euh puisque ça
change hein, quand tu fais ça à travers
une interface, ben tu es l'algorithme de
l'interface de pour pour remplir tes
impôts va finalement te pousser à faire
un certain nombre de choses ou peut
exclure des gens qui savent qui
comprennent pas ce qu'ils sont en train
de voir devant devant eux qui ne
rentrent pas dans les cases ou qui
rentrent pas dans les cases voilà alors
que papier bah tu peux toujours écrire
écrire un petit mot, tu peux négocier,
tu peux dire des choses. Voilà. Et et en
fait, on a on a amené ce débat en Suisse
en posant la question "Est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on protège votre intégrité
numérique au même titre que l'intégrité
physique et psychique ou mentale ?" Et
la population a répondu oui. On a fait
un vote à Genève, c'était 94 % de oui.
Et ce ce thème est rentré dans la
Constitution. Euh neatel, c'était en
novembre 2024, c'était 91 % de Oui. Et
euh le prochain vote sera à Balville et
il y aura Zuric. Euh on a fait une
initiative et où le gouvernement était
contre, voulait pas ça mais euh la
population a voté. Donc, on a un sujet
du numérique qui euh est euh très pris
euh a été complètement euh adopté par la
population. Euh et ça a surpris pas mal
d'analystes et je pense que ce qui ce
que ça a montré c'est que euh il y avait
une captation dans le il y a une
captation qu'on qui est difficile aussi
dans le dans la politique quand on parle
du numérique. C'est une captation tech
euh comment dire euh technicienne en
fait du débat sur le numérique dans dans
la population. On va vous dire euh ah,
on installe des nouveaux systèmes de
surveillance, on installe des nouveaux
systèmes de g d'algorithme, on fait de
l'efficience de l'administration euh et
tout ça c'est pour votre bien mais c'est
très compliqué. Regardez, il y a des des
des pages et des pages et des pages de
loi et de dossiers de tout ce qu'on
veut. Vous avez pas besoin de lire et de
comprendre. On dit que c'est pour votre
bien et vous avez qu'à suivre. Voilà. Et
et ça crée ce ça crée une déconnexion.
Et en fait quand on vient avec des
termes qui sont simples et de dire
est-ce que on veut que vous protégez
votre intégrité numérique ? Est-ce que
vous voulez être en contrôle de votre
relation numérique avec l'État ? Mais là
les gens ils savent répondre. Et donc
c'est c'est un peu le le ça c'est
l'apport que la Suisse a. c'est que dans
le débat euh au quotidien, on peut euh
utiliser des on est obligé en fait dans
la politique puisque c'est une politique
politique de rue, d'utiliser des mots
euh que les gens euh comprennent et qui
comprennent en plus dans trois langues
différentes. Donc il faut que les
concepts marchent dans les trois langues
différentes euh français, allemand,
italien.
Et euh et ensuite une fois que ça
arrive, bah là on voit que quand on
touche le sujet du numérique avec les
bons concepts et les bons mots, c'est
quelque chose qui intéresse les gens. Et
et la et la l'histoire fantastique qui
s'est passée à Genève, c'est que il y a
eu une coalition complètement inattendue
après que
cette votation se soit faite. Il y a une
association des parents d'élèves qui se
battaient depuis des années contre les
écrans à l'école. Donc ils étaient, on
va dire, dans la catégorie des gens qui
étaient plutôt
antitechnologistes euh et qui euh voilà
vous des
amiches, on a pas jusque là, mais voilà,
on les appelle les
amis et et je comprends tout à fait que
ils veulent protéger leurs enfants, ils
disaient "Non, on veut pas des cas
d'écran à l'école et tout ça et et quand
le le la mais le mais leur combat était
inaudible parce qu'en face il y avait
des profs qui disaient "Oui, mais on est
dans une société numérique et Donc on
est obligé d'avoir des écrans à l'école
et on doit leur apprendre aux gens à
utiliser aux enfants à utiliser
l'informatique. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé après le la votation ? Ils ont
fait une pétition dans lequelle il
demandent à l'État de respecter
l'intégrité numérique dans lequel ils
disent il faut utiliser du logiciel
libre, il faut arrêter d'utiliser des
entreprises dont le modèle d'affaires
est la surveillance.
Il faut arrêter d'utiliser des
entreprises dont le modèle d'affair qui
ont un algorithme de de d'attention qui
est lié à leur leur leur leur système.
Il faut euh euh utiliser des sociétés
locales ou des suisses dont dont le
modèle n'est pas la surveillance
justement. Et puis le dernier petit truc
un peu un peu sympa, c'est qu'il disait
il faut que les profs donnent les cours
les devoirs d'abord en classe et
seulement après dans le système
informatique parce qu'en fait il y avait
des profs qui rentraaient chez eux qui
disaient "Ah ben je vais je vais donner
un nouveau devoir au aux enfants dans le
système informatique et ils s'attendaiit
à ce que tous les parents regardent."
Mais il y avait en fait beaucoup de
parents qui regardaient pas ou qui ont
pas encore d'orateur ou que ce soit à la
à la maison. Et donc il y avait un
décalage qui se faisait entre les
enfants et en venant en fait parler
d'intégrité numérique qui est juste la
défense de soi, la protection de soi, de
son autonomie euh individuelle, euh en
mettant ça dans la Constitution, on a
permis à cette association en fait
d'exprimer en fait d'exprimer des des
des demandes qui étaient en fait
extrêmement justes et les
associations Protec de logiciel libre,
les geeks se sont associ associé à ça.
Donc ils ont ils ont fait un appel en
fait de de de signer cette pétition et
même des gens au sein de l'État ont
profité de cette de cette pétition pour
en fait annoncer un passage au logiciel
libre à Genève. Ce qui fait que euh on a
un vrai impact quand on parle du sujet
de la bonne manière, que c'est pas un
truc technique et c'est pas un un outil
de pouvoir. On va dire, on utilise le
numérique pour améliorer l'État et comme
un outil de oui de de de gestion de
l'État et que c'est très technique si on
remet le débat d'un point de vue
politique avec des termes très simples
en disant c'est quoi le rôle de l'humain
là-dedans ? Est-ce que toi en tant que
citoyen, tu veux être en contrôle ou pas
? Et on te pose la question, mais les
gens, ils sont ravis de répondre
là-dedans et ils prennent et ensuite ils
ont des idées qui sont tout à fait
bonnes pour l'éducation de du canton de
Genève. Je voudrais qu'on revienne
ensemble sur ce concept ou sur ce droit
ou cette cette nécessité de protection
de la psyché, de protection du du
caractère de comment on génère la pensée
et comment l'algorithme ou une société
euh prédatrice par aspiration de
données, par contrôle de pouvoir, par
opacité peut influencer la psy la
psyché, l'intégrité de génération de
pensée.
rentre-moi rentre dans des cas concrets.
Je pense qu'on va prendre l'exemple de
Cambridge Analytica. Je pense que c'est
le c'est c'est un des un
des plus beau un des plus beaux
exemples. Cambridge et on est on est où
? On est en Angleterre et puis aux
États-Unis. Ça a été utilisé plusieurs
fois même enfin même dans d'autres pays.
Et en
fait la société Cambridge Analica
va passer un deal avec un parti
politique ou avec un
état. Ça dépend. de plusieurs cas et et
l'idée c'est d'influencer les le
résultat des élections à travers à
l'époque c'était notamment surtout
Facebook. Voilà. Et et comment comment
ils font ? D'abord ils vont ils vont
identifier puisque l'algorithme Facebook
permettait de enfin le le le l'PI de le
connecteur Facebook permettait de
finalement voir tout ce qu'on voulait à
c'est un outil qui est d'abord d'abord
prévu pour la publicité en fait mais qui
permettait de de voir quoi en détail ?
voir en fait de voir les individus où
ils sont, leurs préférences. Voilà, il y
a bien conn voilà, il y a il y a une
quantité de de critères qui étaient
disponibles qui permettait normalement
le but c'était de dire bah vous pouvez
faire de la publicité ciblée pour pour
ces gens-là. Euh et ça se paye he
évidemment. Et là qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils ont
accédé à ces données-là. Euh, ils ont
cherché les endroits où il y avait des
tensions euh électorales, donc les
endroits où où euh pour être le plus
efficace, un petit nombre de gens
pouvaient faire basculer euh le le vote,
hein, de passer de 49 à 51 %. Euh ils
ont identifié ces endroits-là et à
l'intérieur de ces endroits-là, ils ont
identifié les gens qui
euh sur tout ce qu'ils ont fait, ils
l'ont fait par la négative. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont ils ont incité ils ont ils
cherchaient à à déconnecter des gens du
vote. C'està-dire qu'ils cherchaient à
ce que il y avait des gens qui votent
par par conviction. Il y a des gens qui
qui votent un peu par réflexe et qui qui
suivent un petit peu. Et en fait, ils
ont cherché ces gens-là qui étaient
vraiment les très indécis qui allaient
voter. Mais ils les ils ont ils ont
submergé de façon subtile mais ça se ça
se voit pas. Ils ont submergé leur le
fil de Facebook euh avec des
informations qui vont créer de
l'incertitude et qui vont désengager les
gens euh qui ont qui qui vont les
inciter à ne pas aller voter le jour le
jour du vote. Euh et ils arrivaient à
mesurer l'impact de ça et ils ont et je
veux dire le le Brexit a été a été a été
voté avec ça. La première élection de
Trump a été très influencée aussi par
ça.
Donc ça a eu un appart un impact réel et
qui était mesurable et c'est parce que
justement c'était mesurable qu'ils
arrivaient à vendre leur qu'ils
arrivaient à vendre à vendre cela. Donc
ils ont ils ont fait plein de plein
d'élections en Amérique latine et dans
d'autres pays. Est-ce que est-ce que ce
type de d'analyse fine des
populations peut être militarisé pour
emmener une population dans la
dépression, au suicide, à
l'agressivité ou retourner retourner la
perception du réel
? Bien sûr. Alors ça, on le voit, on le
voit dans les alors on le voit en
Russie, on le voit entre enfin entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine où chacun essaie
d'utiliser ces ces techniques là avec
différentes différentes approches.
Est-ce que tu le vois aussi côté
États-Unis, Europe ? Euh est-ce que je
le vois côté États-Unis,
Europe, je je C'est beaucoup plus euh je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus subtil. On
reproche toujours à Elli Musk depuis son
rachat Twitter. d'influencer les
élections en Europe, c'est subtil, c'est
pas subtil, tu l'as détecté. Al ça ça l'
de moins en moins, on va dire, parce que
maintenant il le dit de façon de façon
très euh
euh je veux dire, il participe à des
meetings de la FD en Allemagne, quoi. Je
veux dire, voilà, c'est on en est là.
Euh mais il faut pas il faut il faut pas
faut pas non plus euh sous-estimer le le
le côté euh la la chambre d'éco qui est
générée elle-même par l'algorithme et
même les gens qui même un un même Elon
Mosque alors je pense queils s'en
rendent ils s'en rend compte mais euh on
on on sous-estime cette chambre d'écho
qui est créée par tous ces algorithmes
de publicité et de préférence dans nos
réseaux sociaux et en réalité le La
particularité qui ce qui est dure, c'est
que euh on peut jamais prouver que
quelqu'un a a initié quelque chose de
façon volontaire. En fait, on va on va
avoir des des gens qui savent placer des
informations au bon au bons endroits et
profiter de cette de la création de cet
écho naturelle qui se fait. Ce que font
la plupart des agences aujourd'hui qui
ont des qui ont des équipes comme cela.
Quel type d'agence ?
Euh bah c'est alors les les c'est les
fermes de troll chinoises, les fermes de
troll nord-coréennes, les fermes de
troll russes, il y en a euh al on
connaît pas de ferme de troll euh enfin
il y en a peut-être d'autres mais euh
c'est où d'autres ? En Europe, aux
États-Unis, en Amérique du Sud,
est-ce qu'on les appelle peut-être
différemment ? On les a peut-être On les
On les appelle peut-être différemment.
Ouais. Mais euh mais mais ce qui est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que c'est que
la la complexité est telle, c'est que
même dans des fois dans ces fermes de
troll, alors sauf que sont vraiment
organisé mais en Europe quand tu as des
des des euh des des mobs des gens comme
ça qui participent euh à des à des
mouvements et qui sont incités à agir
sur X dans les réseaux sociaux d'une
certaine manière, en fait ils font
partie de cette de même nous he de de
cliquer sur un truc et de dire et de
participer en fait à un événement comme
ça.
On n pas l'impression des fois même d'y
participer. On n pas l'impression que ce
soit quelque chose de de Je te mets je
te mets dans un cas concret peut-être
hypothétique ou peut-être réel et
ensuite on parlera des Twitter files.
Imagine-toi
que il y a 10 ans, on décide de monter
un groupe avec des intellectuels, des
journalistes, des responsables de
rédaction, des diplomates, des
militaires pour faire du contrediscours.
H ça c'est affiché. Mais en fait,
l'objectif est d'influencer la
perception de la population pour les
amener dans le droit chemin que nous
avons décidé. Est-ce que ce serait aussi
considéré comme une fermatrolle ou ce
serait simplement des intellectuels
ayant le bouclier contre la déraison ?
Si je fais écrire des papiers tout le
temps dans un sens, dans un sens, dans
un sens, porté par des intellectuels
toujours dans un sens, du bourrage de
crâne, du bourrage de crâne et ensuite
peut-être influencer le crollage d'une
d'une intelligence artificielle. On
reviendra sur l'intelligence
artificielle après. Est-ce que c'est pas
utiliser les armes de l'ennemi avec une
légère variante adaptée à nos pays pour
faire exactement la même chose ? Ouais,
je pense qu'il y a une différence
euh stratégique en disant euh euh on
pense à à une chose, on a on a une idée
et ça des gens qui ont des idées, il y
en a plein hein des euh euh et de
vouloir faire avancer idées. Même moi
j'ai mes idées et je les fait avancer
avec euh du lobby du lobbying en Suisse
où je vais voir les gens, je discute
avec eux. Mais tu cherches pas à
détruire toi et tes opposants ? Non, je
cherche pas à détruire mes opposants, ça
non. Euh tu cherches pas non plus à à
ruiner leur réputation.
Euh non, ça ils le font tout seul parce
que voilà. Mais ce que je veux dire, ce
que je veux dire c'est que euh en fait
le le cette je vais te donner un exemple
tout simple pour voir la pour montrer la
puissance parce que moi j'utilise ces
outilslà euh à ma hauteur et simplement
mais ça montre effectivement l'impact
qu'on peut avoir même avec une seule
personne ou un petit groupe de
personnes. Je travaille sur ce droit à
l'intégrité numérique depuis 10 ans et
je suis convaincu de cela. Je le fais ça
parce que j'ai j'ai je suis un un
utopiste dans le numérique et je rêve
d'une d'une d'un d'une démocratie
numérique qui soit qui reste humaniste.
Voilà, ça c'est ça c'est mon ma vision.
Donc je fais je prends mon je fais mon
chemin, je discute avec les gens, avec
des juristes, j'essaie de convaincre les
gens au fur et à mesure. Mais ce que
j'ai fait aussi en même temps, par
exemple, j'ai euh j'ai dit bah je vais
écrire la page Wikipédia de l'intégrité
numérique. Voilà. Donc on a écrit là,
j'aiécris là cette page Wikipédia. Euh
elle a été reprise par des gens des gens
aussi à Wikipédia qui m'ont aidé, qui
ont corrigé. On a on l'a on l'a rempli.
Puis je me suis dit là, on est en
Suisse, on est en Suisse, un pays
trilingue. La majorité c'est allemand.
J'ai dit bon, on va faire le le la page
en allemand. Je me suis forcé à faire la
page en allemand et euh euh une fois que
la page en allemand a été faite, il y a
eu la votation euh à Genève qui s'est
passé et le résultat a été exceptionnel.
Euh les qu'est-ce qu'on fait les gens ?
Les gens, ils ont le jour où ils
devaient voter sur l'intégrité
numérique, ils ont vu un terme qu'ils
peut-être ne connaissait pas, ben ils
sont allés taper sur Google euh
intégrité intégrité moteur de recherche,
on fait pas de pub, désolé. Ils ont tapé
intégrité numérique, ils sont tombés,
ils sont tombés sur la page Wikipédia et
puis ils ont vu ce que ce qui était
écrit. C'était très bien. Voilà. Euh et
puis euh quand le résultat est passé euh
les euh les journaux suiss-allemands ont
commencé à faire un reportage. Enfin, il
il y a eu des un peu des journalistes
qui ont qui se sont euh intéressés au
sujet. Et au journal de 20h,
l'équivalent du 20h du côté suallemand,
un journaliste qui dit voilà, il y a eu
ce vote sur l'intégrité numérique. Et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? lit mot pour mot
la page Wikipédia en allemand. Shunb.
Est-ce que c'est de la
manipulation des masses ? Je pense pas.
Mais ça ça montre que ça montre les les
les impacts. Et là encore, j'ai pas
utilisé d'algorithmes, mais ça montre
que les comportements des gens en fait,
quand tu vas bien placer les
informations euh en ligne euh tu vas tu
vas les les les placer et dans le dans
un dans des mots que les gens vont
comprendre, euh ben en fait ça permet
tout de suite euh euh ça permet une une
diffusion de cette information euh bien
plus forte que ce que tu imagines. Et
là, j'ai pas parlé j'ai pas utilisé des
algorithmes
de de déco qu'utilisent les Fermatroles
ou des faux comptes. J'ai pas me suis
pas amusé à faire des des bottes de faux
compter qui allaient parler de ça. Tu
parles de Wikipédia.
Est-ce que on peut détourner ça ? Toi,
toi tu es utopiste, tu as la main sur le
cœur, tu esse, tu es pur, tu es plein
d'air frais et d'alpage et de bons
chocolat. Et d'ailleurs, on passe le
bonjour à Bernard Rapa. Voilà.
Euh si ça je le pervertis en
utilisant un journaliste pour une source
officielle qui est dans mon réseau pour
discréditer ta
personnalité en utilisant simplement des
modifications sur ta page Wikipédia pour
te faire passer pour un un mangeur de
petit chat et que comme le journaliste
en général est feignant et fénéant et
est sous pression, n'a pas le temps de
travailler et payer au lance-pierre, il
va aller récupérer le plus vite possible
ces petites balises empoisonnées que
j'ai pu mettre sur ta page Wikipédia qui
auront été poussé par ma propre
communauté pour te faire passer pour un
mangeur de bébé chat ou de bébé f ou ce
que tu veux. Est-ce que ça tu as pas
remarqué que Wikipédia pouvait être
perverti par certains points de vue pour
comme tu l'as si bien expliqué porter
une rhthorique ? Est-ce que tu l'as
remarqué ? Oui, oui, oui, bien sûr, bien
sûr, bien sûr. Et le le le poids de de
Wikipédia, le particulier, c'est pas le
Wikipédia en
soi. Parce que dans dans Wikipédia, en
réalité, quand tu quand quand le
mécanisme de Wikipédia ou la la feuille,
la page qui va être un peu controversé
où toi tu vas venir modifier des choses,
en réalité derrière si c'est une page
qui est un peu lue, les gens vont venir
corriger, il va avoir des discussions,
il faut lire le la page des discussions,
c'est assez intéressant. Personne ne lit
ça. Personne le lit mais c'est là qu'on
voit que des fois il y a des débats en
disant "Non, mais c'est pas normal,
pourquoi est-ce que vous faites ça
Euh mais c'est pas ça le problème. Le
problème c'est euh l'intégration de
Wikipédia dans la bul dans dans les dans
les algorithmes mondiaux. À partir du
moment où on va taper un mot clé dans
une un moteur de recherche, il va
utiliser Wikipédia. Les IA vont utiliser
Wikipédia comme source. Euh et en fait
c'est il y a un effet de d'écho et même
une erreur ou une fausse vérité va faire
écho dans le dans dans le reste des des
de tous les systèmes que qu'on peut
utiliser et qui vont amener des gens à
prendre des décisions sur ces ces ces
bouts d'information qui ont pas été
justes. Donc le le c'est c'est bien sûr
on peut ce mécanisme là il est très
puissant en fait. Quels
sont les instruments pour combattre
cette infusion empoisonnée fait par
Pierre, Paul ou Jacques ou le camp de
droite, le camp du milieu, le camp de
gauche ? Est-ce que tu as une idée
comment vaincre, combattre, se préserver
de cette infusion de venin ?
Moi, je pense que et là je vais je vais
être assez radical, c'est que je pense
que on peut pas euh se battre avec les
mêmes armes sur ce niveau-là. Donc moi,
je pense que la société va devoir
arriver à une une conscience collective
qu'on apprend à l'école. Petit, tu es
utopiste toi, non ? Ouais. Ouais. Qu'on
apprend à l'école que tout ce que l'on
voit sur internet, c'est faux.
c'est qu'il y a plus de vérité qui
compte dans le
numérique. Euh tu vois le choc
psychologique que ça peut créer chez les
gens ? Euh oui, complètement, mais en
même temps, surtout quand ils sont
exposés à des à des facteurs stressants
comme économique, de perte de travail,
de violence dans la rue, de violence aux
personnes, de violence dans le discours
politique et
géopolitique. S'ils ne peuvent plus se
baser sur la sainte vérité, ils se
réfugieront dans quoi ? Ben, c'est c'est
là où je voulais en venir. Mais d'abord
euh tu vois, c'est moi c'est j'ai eu eu
la chance euh avec malgré mon âge de
pouvoir être sur internet euh j'ai 47
ans euh d'être sur internet euh le le
premier jour pratiquement d'internet.
Enfin, quel était ta première bécan ?
Euh, un BBC micro à Corne en
1982. J'avais 6 ans. Voilà.
CPC 61 CPC 6128.
Voilà. Et euh et j'avais un père qui
était food technologie et qui au bureau
avait internet. Donc il avait les
réseaux d'avant et puis quand est arrivé
donc 91 il m'a invité au bureau, on a
regardé internet, il y avait pas encore
les images. Il y a pas encore les
images. Que des lignes avec des des des
liens sur mosaïque. Le voilà. Euh et euh
euh et en fait, j'ai tout de suite j'ai
tout de suite appris euh comment était
fait une page web, comment est le HTML,
comment est-ce qu'on l'écrit et tout ça.
À partir du moment où tu comprends
fondamentalement que un humain peut
écrire une page HTML, il peut écrire ce
qu'il veut dedans. Donc tout ce que tout
ce que était tout ce qui apparaissait
sur internet pour moi dès le début
c'était quelque chose qui était fait par
des humains et donc euh enfin ou fait
par fait par des humains ou fait par des
machines qui ont été faites par des
humains. Et donc à partir de ce
moment-là, tout peut être faux. Il y a
il y a il y a il y a le au contraire, on
doit chercher la vraie information à
l'intérieur de ça. Euh et la société en
fait, elle vient d'un monde où euh par
euh aisance, je sais pas, on croyait que
tout était euh vrai. Il y avait une
onapprend à l'école la parole du prof,
c'est du du maître, c'est la la vraie
parole, il faut le croire. Voilà. et euh
et de de faire et de de d'avoir un
changement de société dans lequel on va
dire maintenant tout ce que vous voyez
c'est faux, c'est hyper violent. comment
est-ce qu'on va Mais c'est ce qui moi
m'a permis de de euh de me protéger en
fait de de des informations qui étaient
en ligne et de comprendre comment
fonctionnait le enfin de comprendre à ma
manière
euh comment fonctionne le système autour
de moi et comment on trouve un autre
système ? Ben en fait, c'est de dire
c'est de dire on va on va trouver un
mécanisme où la vérité doit
être prouvée
constamment. Elle doit être prouvée et
il va y avoir un travail, un travail de
de de cryptographie, un travail
de un travail de web of trust. Tu vois,
c'est la notion de de Web of Trust, le
fait que si nous on se rencontre
physiquement et que euh on va échanger
une information euh ben là, je sais que
ça vient vraiment de toi. Euh et on peut
le on peut simuler ça de manière
informatique avec des de la
cryptographie euh forte entre avec une
communication sécurisée entre nous. Euh
euh ça veut dire qu'en fait la
l'information vraie, il faut aller la la
chercher auprès des autres personnes.
Alors, tu disais par essence, moi je
dirais par facilité. Euh si par facilité
l'Union européenne par
exemple met des vérificateurs
assermentés pour dire ça c'est bien, ça
c'est pas bien, ça c'est faux, ça c'est
conspi, ça c'est vilain, pourquoi ça
marchera pas ? March pas mais ça
marchera pas parce que ils auront
toujours eux un intérêt particulier. ça
il ils seront peut-être de bonne
volonté, hein, mais en fait à un moment
donné, ils vont devoir trancher et ils
vont trancher en fonction de qui les pay
de qui les paye tout simplement, voilà,
de qui les payures. Est-ce qu'ils vont
perdre leur job s'ils disent une
connerie ? Euh euh s'ils s'opposent au
consensus. S'ils s'opposent au
consensus, par exemple. Exactement.
Ouais. Euh et tout le travail qui est en
train de se faire maintenant justement,
c'est on on travaille sur des nouvelles
méthodes pour trouver le consensus et
une des méthodes dont on a dont on don d
don don que l'on connaît aujourd'hui,
bah c'est la la preuve de travail par
exemple. La preuve de travail, c'est une
méthode de consensus. C'est ce qui est
utilisé dans Bitcoin euh ou alors pour
justement s'assurer que la transaction
financière, elle s'est réellement
passée. En fait, c'est un des milieux
d'ordinateurs qui vont travailler
ensemble. Ils vont montrer qu'ils ont
fait un travail pour sécuriser et pour
rendre cette transaction figée dans le
temps et et la la rendre vraie. En fait,
il y a une vérité dans dans dans un
algorithme de preuve de travail. Est-ce
que tu as entendu parler, on reviendra
sur tout ça dans pas très longtemps.
Est-ce que tu pourrais me parler des
Twitter files ?
Écoute, je j'ai j'ai pas vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup creusé creusé la
chose. Euh est-ce que tu as entendu
parler du fait que Facebook du temps de
Biden était connecté avec des services
étatiques américains pour faire terre ?
Oui. Oui. Des opinions ? Non non, je
connais je connais je connais les
principes. Je connais les
princips. Euh est-ce que tu en as
entendu parler ? Est-ce que tu pourrais
me le délayer un petit peu ou expliquer
à ma communauté ce qui s'est passé avec
ça ?
Alors, ce qui s'est euh ce qui s'est
passé, c'est
que euh
[Musique]
euh la le il y a une il y a une
collusion telle en fait entre les
réseaux sociaux euh enfin les grands
groupes tech de manière générale et
l'État. On
on peut redire le terme, c'est le le le
capitalisme de surveillance. C'est chos
comment ? C'est Shosana Zubof qui a
décrit qui a décrit cela. bouquin
excellent bouquin justement et qui
montre justement les les liens entre les
le le le acteurs publics et le secteur
privé dans la captation de données et
l'analyse de données et c'est pas une
relation forcément toujours bonne hein
parce que Snowdon nous a montré que des
quand quand les prix quand les boîtes
privées veulent pas donner accès à
certaines données, l'État vient les
prendre d'elle-même en mettant des
capteurs des capteurs pour écouter les
flux les flux de données
Euh mais à un moment donné effectivement
les le le les groupes en fait tels que
Twitter, Facebook et autres sont
tellement gros que euh quand un état
vient quand l'État américain vient et
leur met une pression telle en terme de
de en leur disant vous vous devez nous
donner accès et vous devez aussi pour
des questions de d'ordre
public
nous supprimer un certain type de
contenu
ou euh supprimer en fait les effets que
eux ils voient négatifs de l'algorithme
déco qui est généré dans le dans le
réseau social.
Mais en fait, on s'est retrouvé par
facilité par les gens chez Facebook,
chez Twitter qui ont en fait ouvert des
lignes simples où dès qu'il y avait une
instruction qui arrivait, ils appuyaient
sur un bouton et puis ça ça supprimait
des contenus et ça ou ça chanait des
contenus des gens, ça invisibilise des
gens et ainsi de suite. Voilà. Euh c'est
quelque chose que l'on voit dans deux
domaines. On le voit dans le dans le
toute l'industrie du blanchiment
d'argent. C'est déjà le cas en fait. Euh
le blanchement d'argent, c'est un
système où euh euh les euh euh les euh
euh les les banques et les
intermédiaires financiers euh doivent en
fait euh faire de la censure au
quotidien à travers de des lois qui
s'appellaient des lois de euh sur les
sur les sanctions. Donc on censure des
gens, on censure des des types
d'activités qui sont qui
sont faites avec certains pays et et si
la justification à la base, elle est
peut-être elle est très très bonne parce
que voilà, on dit on un mauvais régime,
un régime qui est en train de tuer des
gens et on veut pas envoyer de l'argent
pour aider tel terroriste ou qui
continue à tuer des gens, c'est c'est
bien normal de mettre des sanctions.
Voilà, ça c'est bien. Et en fait la
manière dont ça a été faite, c'est que
ça crée en fait une une
industrie de compliance de de en
français ou en Suisse. Donc en français,
on dit
de
euh je Il y a combien de zéos à un
milliard ? À 1 milliard, il y en a neuf,
hein. C'est bien. Euh euh la compliance,
c'est euh comment on va dire ? Bon bref,
en tout cas de conformité. Voilà, merci.
conformité. Euh donc la conformité
juridique, c'est quoi ? C'est des gens
dans les dans dans les banques et tout
ça qui vont vérifier si les transactions
qui sont que que toi tu fais que moi je
fais sont conformes. Et en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que on leur a mis
tellement de pression à ces gens-là,
mais c'est des pressions pas forcément
directes euh devancé.
C'est des des pressions en fait leur
carrière va pas avancer si ils les
suivent pas. Euh ça veut dire que si ils
ne mettent pas en place euh euh ces ces
ces censures-là, ils vont être
responsables pénalement eux-mêmes.
Voilà. Et donc en fait les gens
protègent leur arrière et euh ils vont
faire du zè. Et donc au lieu de euh
d'aller chercher euh euh l'essence de la
loi sur les sanctions et de dire je vais
si jamais on voit cette personne là ou
on envoie de l'argent à tel terroriste,
on arrête la leflux. En fait, ils vont
commencer à poser des questions à tout
le monde et puis dès que tu viens avec
euh 100 balles en liquide déposé à la
banque, on va dire "Ah, il faut un
dossier, pourquoi euh il
faut donc nous les montants c'est un peu
plus élevé mais euh euh mais mais c'est
vrai que euh il y a toute une toute une
euh une surveillance financière et une
censure financière qui a été mis en
place qui est décorrélée en fait de la
réalité économique parce qu'on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que ce que ça coûte
C'est débile hein, ça coûte 200 € pour
chaque euro attraper. Euh donc à la
société ça coûte 200 €. C'est quoi ta
source ? Euh c'est des il y a alors il y
a il y a Alexandre Tachenko qui est qui
est venu sur ton plateau même euh qui a
fait tout un article sur
justement les euh qui a fait sur les
dérives de la surveillance financière
euh et qui sort ce chiffre là. Il y a un
autre chiffre aussi d'un autre donc il
cite les rapports dans son dans son
article. Un autre chiffre aussi c'est
que la la l'efficacité finan
l'efficacité donc le de ce qu'on attrape
des
fonds liés au terrorisme ou enfin qu'on
devrait attraper au à cause du
blanchement d'argent enfin des lois anti
blanchement d'argent. En gros, on
attrape 0 entre 0,1 % et 1 % des fonds
sont réellement attrapés par le système.
Ce que ce que je veux dire par là, c'est
que c'est un système qui est pas du tout
efficace mais qui a été mis en place par
les États et sur un secteur privé et qui
censure
les là des transactions et qui en fait
pousse aussi à l'autocensure,
c'est-à-dire que les les
les ou à l'automodération, les banques
vont vont vont faire du zel sur un
certain nombre de de d'activités
financières. Et en fait, c'est le même
mécanisme euh dans les dans les dans les
réseaux sociaux. Il y a un peu quelque
chose de similaire. Euh sauf que là, on
touche sur les communications des gens.
On passe d'une communication financière
à une communication euh euh verbale ou
enfin écrite. Et euh et c'est vrai que
les gens, ils ont accepté. On accepte de
se faire censurer financièrement. Ils
ils acceptent moins de se faire censurer
d'un point de vue de communication.
Je voudrais que tu me parles et après on
reviendra un petit peu sur les Twitter
files peut-être si tu as des choses à
rajouter. Je voudrais que tu me parles
de la liberté d'expression de la
censure. Vaste thème sur internet sur le
fait que par exemple en Angleterre il y
a des gens qui se sont retrouvés en
zonzon parce que bah ils avaient écrit
des trucs dégueulasses. Ouais, c'est
normal, c'est pas normal. Il y a des
gens qui sont retrouvés par exemple aux
États-Unis shadow banés parce qu'ils
étaient peut-être trop conservateurs ou
trop religieux ou trop trop qui pour toi
met ce type de critère de censure ? Quel
peuvent être ou quels sont les effets
délétaires de ça ? Est-ce que c'est
peut-être bénéfique ? Quel est ton point
de vue là-dessus sur la dégradation de
la liberté d'expression ? Ouais. Et sur
la censure ? Moi ma vision c'est euh que
la liberté d'expression en fait sur
internet, elle est euh techniquement
total. Ça veut dire que si tu as si tu
as les capacités euh de un peu technique
de euh de de diffuser de l'information
sur internet, tu peux diffuser ce que tu
veux.
Après euh tu vas avoir en fait le réseau
qui va euh enfin tu vas avoir une
réaction si ce que tu dis et euh n'est
pas acceptable pour l'environnement dans
lequel tu vas dire. Je te donne un cas
concret. Si je vois par exemple madame
Michu faire de l'apologie du terrorisme.
Ouais.
Il faut la censurer, pas la censurer,
faut lui expliquer que c'est pas bien,
faut l'emmener devant la justice. Si
elle a des capacités techniques pour
pouvoir
s'anonymiser, parce que c'est une madame
Mich professionnelle et geek qui a tout
un tas de de connaissances, si elle fait
de l'apologie du terrorisme ou si elle
fait de l'apologie d'un génocide ou elle
si elle fait de l'apologie de
l'esclavage, il faut pour toi la laisser
parler, pas la laisser parler, il faut
lui mettre la police, il faut lui mettre
la prison, faut faut faire quoi ? Il
faut avoir un rapport pédagogique, faut
protéger les autres contre ce
déversement de haine. Quel est ton point
de vue là-dessus ? C'est ce que je
disais un petit peu tout à l'heure,
c'est que le le euh on a besoin que
l'information soit libre. L'information
doit être libre et la communication doit
être libre au au max au maximum. Enfin,
ça c'est ma ça c'est ma ça c'est ma ma
vue. Tu rejoins Musk
là-dessus. Ouais, mais dans la pratique,
il le fait pas. dans le pratique, il lui
il fait aussi de la censure. Euh c'est
pas c'est donc il dit ch concret cas
concret euh bah en fait il sur sur sur
Twitter, il y a aussi des termes qui
sont aujourd'hui plus qui sont
automatiquement bannis et qui euh alors
je sais pas quel les les quels termes.
Bon il a fait une grosse chasse au
pédophile. En tous les cas,
il a fait une grosse chasse au
pédophile. On va pas se on va pas
évidemment je vais pas la je vais pas la
euh on va on va pas pleurer sur les sur
les pédophiles, on est d'accord. Voilà,
on va pas pleurer sur eux. Euh euh mais
cette chasse sur les pédophiles euh elle
existe elle a toujours existé et euh
elle a toujours été très efficace parce
qu'on voit que en réalité euh les euh
enfin l'accès euh au matériel
pédopnographique euh a plutôt euh enfin
moi c'est moi l'impression que j'ai.
Après c'est je je pas de quoi mesurer ou
je connais pas les la mesure mais ce que
je vois c'est que ça a plutôt diminué.
C'estàd que c'était quand même beaucoup
plus facile il y a 20 ans de ça
d'accéder à des du matériel comme ça que
qu'aujourd'hui. Tu as fait tomber des
serveurs quand tu étais jeune de péo ?
On s'est amusé à faire ce genre de
tradition. Longue tradition. Ouais,
exactement. Ouais. Ou à ou à dénoncer
des gens à la police et puis qui
savaient pas trop quoi trop quoi en
faire à ce moment-là euh de l'époque.
Voilà, c'était c'était c une époque une
époque intéressante entre ça et les
trucs les sites néonazis.
Mais le euh ça a laissé des séquelles
quand tu traquais les pédos ? Euh ouais
bien sûr. Ouais ouais je pas tombé sur
des microfilms un peu chelous des années
70. Écoute il y avait pas que ça. Il y
avait des trucs aussi beaucoup plus
récents des années 90 mais 90. Mais
le c'est pas c'est pas une période qui
était qui était très très drôle. Ouais.
Quel type de Squel tu as vu que tu as eu
?
Euh j'ai j'ai euh euh Tu as vu la
noirceur de certains ? Bien sûr. Mais
mais ça t'a fait peur ? Ça m'a fait
peur. Et en même temps, tu vois ce que
j'ai fait avec mes enfants parce que mes
enfants bon, ils sont grands maintenant
mais je leur ai laissé en fait une
totale liberté sur internet.
pas de filtre parental. Pas de filtre
parental parce que je voulais que il ils
apprennent en fait à à à faire ce chemin
de recherche à travers la toile. Ils se
sont tu les as laissé se
mratiser avec ton a ton aide. Tu sais ce
que ça veut
dire quand tu tu t'auto-empoisonnes de
petites doses toxiques et ça te permet
de t'immuniser et de reconnaître là où
c'est en Exactement. Ouais. Exactement.
Euh et et je sais que je sais que ils
sont tombés dans des boucles peut-être
de films d'horreur ou de d'histoire
d'horreur ou des choses comme ça quand
ils étaient un petit peu petits. Euh et
ça les a sûrement un petit peu
traumatisé euh
euh des fois mais euh ont posé des
questions pour pouvoir apaiser leur
angoisse où ils t'ont expliqué ce qu'ils
ont pu voir parce que tu étais
transparent ou pas ? Ouais, on discute
un petit peu ça. Ouais, on discute. Non,
mais ça aussi après, ils discutent avec
leurs leur leurs potes, ils font ce
chemin-là et puis euh moi ce que je leur
ai expliqué c'est les mécanismes. En
fait, je leur ai expliqué les mécanismes
d'algorithme ou comment tu passes d'une
vidéo à l'autre, d'un d'un lien à un
autre, ainsi de suite et comment tu peux
euh reconnaître
finalement ces choses-là. Et ça ça leur
a fait du bien. Je vois qu'aujourd'hui
ils maîtrisent internet d'une manière
que leurs potes à l'école savent pas
maîtriser. Euh et
quel type de débrief tu as eu avec eux ?
Je te je te coupe, c'est fait exprès,
hein. Quel Si si tu veux pas en parler,
tuen parles pas, mais est-ce que tu as
été amené à débriefer ? Par exemple, il
y a un de tes gamins qui a été choqué
parce que il a vu le conflit le conflit
syrien avec des terroristes qui mettent
des rafales de Kalashnikov dans le
derrière la tête avec une tête qui
explose ou des homosexuels balancés du
9e étage par Daesh ou Al-Qaïda. Est-ce
que est-ce que il y a ce type de de
situation où il ils t'ont demandé de
l'aide ? Non, ils m'ont pas demandé
l'aide. On a pas on en a pas parlé et je
sais pas s'ils ont s'ils ont vu ça.
Voilà, ça je sais pas. Voilà. Euh mais
euh mais si ça a mis tombé là-dessus, on
en on en parlerait volontiers. Voilà. En
Suisse, il y a euh une politique
étatique pour euh avoir un rôle
pédagogique au sein de la famille.
Est-ce que l'État vous donne des petites
cartes pour expliquer aux enfants ? Euh
est-ce que il y a je dirais est-ce que
c'est comme la prévention antidrogue en
Suisse ?
Non non non non. tu vas avoir tu vas
avoir des des des cours de de
bureautique. Euh et puis euh si ton
gamin il est un petit peu smart et qu'il
commence à bidouer avec les ordinateurs,
il va se faire punir par
l'école. Donc on en est encore là.
Ouais, il y a du chemin encore. Euh
c'est arrivé à mon fils. Il s'est fait
punir parce qu'il a changé ses bulletins
? Non non, ça ça il aurait pu mais il a
pas moi je lui ai dit tu touches pas aux
notes et tu touches pas aux autres
personnes. Tu doxes pas. Tu doxes pas
non plus. Pas ça veut dire quoi doxer ?
Doxer ça veut dire de révéler la
l'identité de la de la personne qui est
qui est en face. Toi tu es un vrai
pirate. La vie privée c'est sacré. C'est
bien. Et stalker ça veut dire quoi ?
stocker, ça veut dire suivre une
personne ou la la tu vois la la la
essayer de suivre tous ses pas et de la
de de la comprendre au maximum.
Euh, il a été puni parce que il avait
installé Linux sur une machine
Windows à côté de d'autres choses qu'il
avait fait. Enfin, non, les autres
choses, il a pas été puni pour voilà.
Mais mais au moins, il a gardé la ligne
de on touche pas aux gens. Voilà, c'est
ça que je disais. Je disais tu touches
pas aux gens. tu touches pas aux notes,
tu touches pas aux gens. Euh le
matériel, c'est matériel. Voilà, changer
le le système d'exploitation d'une
machine, c'est pas très grave, mais euh
c'est réversible. C'est réversible.
Voilà, exactement. Mais ça a quand même
créé pas mal de problèmes dans dans dans
l'école.
Euh oui, pour en pour en revenir au au
matériel euh dur, euh je pense que
euh le
le on on a on a aussi ce phénomène où en
fait le le l'outil technique, le le
réseau euh est utilisé euh
pour palier en fait à des manquements
dans la dans dans la société au niveau
des des gens directement par et c'est
l'État qui utilise cela. Et euh et en
fait quand on parle de
pédopornographie euh euh en réalité il y
a deux phénomènes. Il y a d'abord les
gens qui commettent qui commettent les
actes et là on sait que c'est
principalement dans les familles. On
sait que c'est des gens il y a des il y
a des il y a des des victimes réelles
par rapport à ça et il y a il y a une
vraie défaillance dans la
société pour adresser cela. Mais c'est
des moyens humains. C'est pas des moyens
techniques qu'il faut. C'est des moyens
humains. C'est des moyens quand tu as un
gamin ou une gamine qui dit quelque
chose à l'école, il faut pouvoir
l'écouter. Et alors qu'on a eu tellement
de cas où en fait on écoutait pas et on
retrouvait après le gamin mort ou
violet. Euh euh et après il y a le
deuxième phénomène qui est euh la
diffusion d'images
pédopornographiques euh où là euh il y a
il y a il y a il y a un débat moral
extrêmement fort à avoir euh qui est euh
euh à quel point euh
euh est-ce que des gens qui ont des des
humains on ont le ont leur ont leur ont
leurs impulsions et à quel point une
impulsion comme ça, on considère qu'elle
doit juste pas exister ou c'est une
déviance une déviance une déviance
qu'elle doit de qu'elle doit exister ou
pas exister et et et en fait je préfère
que des gens comme ça aillent se faire
aent consulter un psi ou passent
à et une démarche en fait où il puisse
dépasser cette déviance là plutôt que de
se
euh plutôt que euh plutôt qu'on qu'on
cache les yeux en disant ça existe pas.
Et voilà, tu vois euh c'est c'est très
compliqué comme débat et évidemment on
va on va on va il y aura toujours cette
tension là, elle va elle va toujours
exister en fait.
Tu travailles pour NIM ? Oui. C'est quoi
NIM ? NIM c'est un réseau
d'anonymisation. Donc on a créé un un
réseau de communication euh de
communication. tu peux euh surfer sur
internet, tu peux envoyer des messages,
tu peux connecter plein de logiciels
dessus et et euh et en fait le le le
aujourd'hui euh la plupart des
communications sont chiffrées.
C'est-à-dire que euh moi je vais te
parler, quelqu'un qui va regarder notre
communication va pas pouvoir lire ce
qu'il y a dedans. Ça dépend où il est
positionné. Ça dépend où il est
positionné. Mais s'il regarde le le s'il
regarde la communication, elle est
chiffrée, il va pas pouvoir lire. Si je
t'envoie un message sur signal par
exemple, on va quelqu'un d'externe va
pas pouvoir lire. Par contre, tu es sûr
de Tu es sûr de ça ? Ouais, sur signal,
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt bon. Euh par
contre, il peut savoir que je suis en
train de parler avec toi, ça se voit.
Et donc l'idée d'un réseau
d'anonymisation, c'est de
cacher qui parle avec
qui. Euh et c'est en fait euh un des
critères fondamentaux pour les
algorithmes, les algorithmes de
préférence. En fait, ils vont regarder
ton graphe social et ils vont voir avec
qui tu parles, avec qui tu es ami, avec
qu'est-ce c'est ta qui parl avec qui tu
parles, avec qui sont combien de temps
tu parles combien de temps com quelle
fréquence ? Exactement. À quelle heure ?
À quelle heure ? Euh si tu parles avec
et on s'est rendu compte que euh si on
mesure ça, on arrive euh à savoir ce que
tu dis sans sa sans lire ce que tu dis.
Je schématise, tu rentres à 18h à la
maison et tuenvoies un message à ta
femme. Ça parle sûrement de bouffe ou de
gosse, tu vois.
Ça c'est bien mal connaître ma femme.
Et euh mais euh et donc en fait l'idée
de Nî, c'est euh de cacher avec qui tu
parles. Donc tu tu établis un canal de
communication direct avec quelqu'un euh
et non seulement le contenu est chiffré,
mais l'existence de cette communication,
il est est chiffré aussi.
Et ça permet d'échapper à des
algorithmes qui vont eux fonctionner sur
ce qu'on appelle les métadonnées,
c'est-à-dire les données de connexion,
les données de temps, enfin voilà tout
ce qu'on a décrit tout à l'heure. Ça ça
fonctionne que si ton environnement est
installé NIM est sécurisé. Non. Alors
c'est un bout. C'est qu'un bout.
C'està-dire que on a l'appareil dans
lequel tu es. On a même toi en tant que
personne parce que tu peux aussi euh il
y a toute une chaîne en fait de sécurité
entre deux personnes qui veulent
discuter euh et
le les appareils sont un des éléments de
la de la chaîne. Le réseau internet au
milieu en est un autre. Les gens sont
sont les autres. Donc nous, on se
concentre sur cette communication entre
deux appareils. On va pas chercher à
protéger l'appareil en lui-même. Ça, il
y a
d'autres d'autres manières de faire. Et
donc on peut on peut on peut réduire
enfin on peut augmenter la la sécurité
en fait au niveau des appareils. Mais
par contre euh euh ce que quand tu as un
un adversaire qui veut essayer de de de
t'attaquer, quel qu'il soit euh un
gouvernement hostile contre un reporter
de guerre gouvernement mais un
algorithme de publicité. Euh enfin, il y
a plein de des entreprises qui vont
faire du business intelligence, qui vont
faire de l'analyse des des de leurs
concurrent ou toutes sortes de choses.
Euh un stalker, quelqu'un qui va essayer
de te suivre à la à la trace comme un
stalker qui suit les agents de la DGSE
jusqu'en bas de chez eux avec leur
cookie publicitaire par exemple ou qui
ou qui surveillent les transporteurs de
fond par exemple. Je sais pas si vous
avez les mêmes grands retardés de la de
la de la de l'hygiène informatique en
Suisse, mais nous par exemple, il y a il
y a des journalistes qui ont acheté euh
un fichier avec certaines cookies
publicitaires et ils sont amusés à les
recouper euh avec quelques
géolocalisations. qui sont eu les
téléphones qui avaient Alisé, les
téléphones qui se baladaient dans le QG
de la
DGSE et par exemple Strava qui
permettait de remonter quels sont quels
étaient les militaires en opération
extérieure, quand combien de temps ils
faisaient leur footing, autour de quel
périmètre, à telle heure et ainsi de
suite. Imagine-toi, je suis à Corille du
Nord pour prendre que j'ai envie de
faire du ciblage, faire changer, faire
chanter un agent de la DGSE parce que je
lui dis écoute mon pote, je sais à
quelle heure tes enfants ils sortent de
l'école où je sais que ta femme elle
avait faire du yoga ou du pilate à telle
heure ou par exemple je sais que X ou Y
fight checker sont à gauche et à droite
et j'ai pas envie parce que je suis
contre eux, j'ai j'arrive à à les
stalker. Comment t'expliques
que il y ait pas de l'hygiène
informatique à très haut niveau ? Mais
parce qu'on apprend pas à l'école, c'est
tout. Enfin, je veux dire les les quand
tu as des quand tu as des des des
milliers ou de dizaines de milliers de
fonctionnaires qui ou de de gens qui
travaillent dans des entreprises qui
sont euh qui ont été je sais pas moi,
formés pour être policiers qui font leur
carrière dans làdedans, on leur a jamais
appris parce que c'était le chiffrement.
On a jamais appris à à installer un
Linux sur un système. Euh, ils savent
ils savent pas faire. Donc
euh, on leur fournit des outils euh qui
savent utiliser et et ça ça montre un
peu l'ensemble. Alors, bien sûr, à
l'intérieur de ça, tu as sûrement des
petit des équipes qui maîtrisent
totalement leur leur truc. Et puis euh
en Suisse, on a des on a des on a des
surtout au niveau de euh pas au niveau
des portes de police, mais au niveau des
des des consultants qui travaillent avec
la les forces de police lorsqueil y a un
problème, là on a des gens de très très
très haut niveau qui sont disponibles et
qui aident.
Euh mais euh mais c'est euh mais c'est
un un c'est un ensemble de de culture.
C'est la culture générale, hein. Et tu
peux pas euh dans une population euh qui
est complètement euh non éduquée à
l'informatique, euh tu peux pas espérer
que euh tout l'appareil de d'un état euh
soit bien équipé.
Revenons à ton business, Nim. Euh, je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable. Je
vais
dire mais ça va pas la tête de donner un
bloc renforcé de sécurité de
communication parce que ça peut être
utilisé par les pédos, les terroristes,
les états
béliqueux grâce au au canal, au pipe, au
tuyau que tu vas pouvoir créer où tu
génères du bruit, où c'est endurci euh
très profondément pour éviter de te
faire attraper tes paquets.
Moi, je je fais une expérience de pensée
façon au ministère de l'intérieur. Je
dis donne-moi les clés parce que si tu
me donnes pas les clés, tu facilites
l'augmentation de la
délinquence, le le la délinquence
financière, la délinquence de tout ce
que toutes les les déviances qu'on vient
de citer précédemment. Qu'est-ce que tu
peux répondre à ces gens-là ? Bah, je
réponds déjà une première chose. Je
regarde l'histoire en fait. Et
l'histoire, elle est assez simple. Quand
tu quand on passe avec Internet, au
début Internet tout toutes les
communications, elles étaient euh non
chiffré, transparente, hein. Et euh et
euh et on avait plein de problèmes de
terrorisme, de pédopornographie, de tout
ce que tu veux. Ça c'était déjà là hein.
Il y a pas c'est pas des c'est pas des
nouvelles choses. Et à un moment
donné euh euh les gens commence à dire
"Ouais, c'est un peu quand même un peu
embêtant pour des questions de
confidentialité ou de payer faire des
paiements de cartes en carte de crédit
pour faire des paiements à
distance de faire ça sur un un réseau
complètement transparent. Donc qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé ? On a inventé le TLS
HTTPS et donc c'est le fameux petit
cadna que tu as sur ton
navigateur. Et je sais plus à quelle
date à un moment les navigateurs se sont
organisés en disant maintenant c'est
fini, on force le chiffrement de cela.
Euh, il y a eu une levée de bouclier de
gouvernement en disant à ce moment-là
oui, mais on va pas pouvoir on va on va
pas pouvoir se battre contre les pédos,
contre les narcotrafiquants, ainsi de
suite. On a besoin de ça. Qu'est-ce que
ça a enclenché en fait ? ça a enclenché
un boom du commerce
électronique. Ça a changé ça, ça a
complètement modifié en fait la la face
d'internet mais de façon
positive dans le sens
où euh il y a des des des Ouais le
commerce le le commerce international,
les échanges ont pu ont exploser grâce
grâce à ça.
Et aujourd'hui, si on
regarde les risques que ça avait que ça
avait, est-ce que ça a vraiment modifié
? Est-ce que ça a permis à plus de péd
pornographie, de plus de terrorisme et
ainsi de suite ? Non, pas vraiment en
fait. Voilà.
Euh aujourd'hui euh le l'industrie de la
captation de données, le le capitalisme
de surveillance de le capitalisme de
surveillance dont on parlait, il est tel
que toutes les activités que l'on a
aujourd'hui sur internet, que ce soit
juste parler entre nous ou acheter
quelque chose est capté par des grosses
des grosses structures. OK et qui en
fait valorisent toutes ces données là.
Et donc si demain on a un système qui
nous permet d'échapper à cela en cachant
avec qui on parle parce que c'est ça qui
eux ils regardent quel site on va à qui
on parle avec qui on communique avec qui
on on échange. Si on se si on se cache
de ça, on en fait on enlève la
possibilité au capitalisme de
surveillance de venir extraire cette
valeur auprès de nous. Et donc nous, on
s'attend à ce que dans un internet qui
aura anonymisé les communications, donc
pas juste chiffré de bout en bout, mais
euh chiffré aussi pour qu'on ne puisse
pas savoir qui parle avec qui, il y aura
un boom économique parce que la valeur
restera bien plus euh euh ancrée en fait
entre les gens qui sont les acteurs
économiques qui sont réellement en train
d'échanger. Quelle était ma question ?
Et ta question ta question c'était euh
est-ce que vous avez pas de pression
est-ce que vous avez pas des gens qui
vont dire euh ah mais vous faites un un
outil qui va être utilisé par les euh
par les euh par les mauvais acteurs ? Je
te donne un cas concret. dans les dans
les années 80, on mettait les gens sur
écoute. Oui. Mais ce que ce que je veux
dire, c'est que euh l'arg le le le il y
a un argument de dire il y a un argument
de dire euh que il y a une un
développement économique, enfin il y a
un bienfait pour la société qui est
largement supérieur à à écouter en fait
à à casser les à avoir des des
communications de mauvaise qualité. En
fait, le pour nous la la communication
sécurisée et la communication chiffrée
et la communication anonyme euh c'est un
droit fondamental, c'est quelque chose
qui doit être euh accessible à tout le
monde et en fait il peut pas y avoir de
demi-mesure. Tu peux pas avoir une bague
d'or qui soit disponible. C'est quoi une
bague d'or pour ceux qui ne savent pas ?
D'ailleurs, comme tu es vieux, tu dirais
bacorifice d'ailleurs
bacorifice euh une bague d'or, c'est une
porte dérobée. Une porte dérobée qui
c'est une sorte de Ouais, je sais pas,
une faille dans le système ou une clé
dans le système euh qui peut être
utilisée par quelqu'un pour finalement
ouvrir le
le déchiffrer et regarder la
communication qui se passe réellement.
Euh et aujourd'hui, il y a une pression.
Euh ça a été euh ça a presque été voté
en France il y a il y a quelques
semaines. Euh il y a une pression des
gouvernements euh pour imposer des bacs
d'or euh dans les systèmes de
cryptographie et euh euh et en fait euh
Meridit Waker de signal, elle le dit euh
régulièrement, elle le dit il y a pas
c'est blanc ou noir. C'est soit il y a
une soit il y a une bague d'or et à ce
moment-là la sécurité est complètement
détruite, elle est disponible pour tout
le monde. Soit il y en a pas. Le
système, il est sûr pour tout le monde.
Que tu sois criminel, que tu sois
quelqu'un qui un journaliste, que tu
sois un gouvernement, ça change, ça
change rien. Il n'y a pas de de
d'intermédiaire. Donc, il faut choisir à
un moment ce que l'on veut. Et et
l'argument euh c'est de dire que enfin
moi mon argument c'est euh que le
bénéfice pour la société d'un système
chiffré sans bac d'or, il est largement
supérieur que d'avoir une société qui
soit pas chiffrée. Parce que là, quand
tu es pas protégé par le chiffrement, tu
es susceptible euh d'être influencé. tu
es tu es victime de tu tu peux être
victime de cette captation de données,
de ces influences et en fait tu perds
beaucoup plus en tant que société que si
tu as une des communications chiffré. Il
y a pas de compromis à faire entre ces
deux ces deux étatsl. Tu as suivi
l'affaire Sky, le réseau Sky. Tu as
suivi l'affaire du patron de télégram.
Qu'est-ce que tu en a pensé ? Alors euh
j'ai suivi le patron le l'affaire de
patron de télégram. J'ai même écrit un
petit article
dessus. Euh l'affaire Telegram, c'était
très intéressant parce que euh Telegram
était une est un service qui n'était qui
pas
chiffré et centralisé.
Mais la personnalité de Pavel Dur
faisait que
il donner l'impression à tout le monde
qu'il résistait à l'influence russe et
l'influence américaine. Voilà. Et
française. Et française aussi. Fran plus
d'influence et et française aussi. Euh
et il s'était réfugié à Dubaï. Il était
financièrement indépendant. Il avait
beaucoup de Bitcoin. Euh
euh et euh et en fait, il y avait un
sentiment de sécurité très fort quand
tuis Telégram. Mais nous, on savait très
bien que c'était pas chiffré et pas pas
et centralisé. Donc, il y avait vraiment
une grosse faille.
euh on avait enfin la les utilisateurs
avaient une notion en fait de de dire de
de penser que il donnait pas les
données. Euh ce qui s'est passé c'est
que euh bah ça la pression a été trop
forte pour lui. Euh il a il a il a
craqué. Euh est-ce qu'il s'est venu
alors il est venu en France ? Est-ce que
c'est l'influence des Français ? Enfin
est-ce que est-ce qu'il est venu se
réfugier en France ? Est-ce que c'est
est-ce que il a été arrêté par les
Français ? Ça, je veux pas rentrer. On
peut on peut on peut parler, on peut il
y a beaucoup de supputations qui qui
sont là, mais je pense que c'est c'est
le moins pire des scénarios pour lui et
le fait que ce soit le moins pire des
scénarios pour lui me laisse penser
qu'il y a peut-être eu un arrangement,
mais ça c'est vraiment des supputations.
Mais en tout cas, ce qui s'est passé le
jour même où il l'a été il a été arrêté
en France, le gouvernement ukrainien a
dit "À partir de maintenant, vous
utilisez plus Telegram."
et Telégramé en Ukraine et en fait même
le gouvernement ukrainien ne savait pas
si les Russes pouvaient écouter et en
fait le fait que Pavel Durf est arrivé a
été arrêté en France ben l'équipe de
télégram n'a pas pu résister aux
demandes russes américaines et autres et
donc voilà le système s'est effondré
aujourd'hui Telegram n'est considéré
comme pas
sûr. Et d'ailleurs, tout le monde a
bougé sur enfin tous ceux qui veulent
les discussions sûr sont passés sur
signal. Signal n'est pas parfait. signal
est aussi centralisé, mais au moins les
communications sont chiffrées de bout en
bout. Euh donc au moins le contenu des
des discussions est pas est pas euh est
pas disponible. Euh et c'est là où nous
avec NIM, on veut rajouter un un élément
supplémentaire, une couche
supplémentaire, c'est aussi de casser
cette relation entre les les de entre
ceux qui communiquent. Donc en fait
d'avoir une application qui permet de
communiquer mais aussi sans savoir qui
communique avec qui. Euh c'est
disponible ça ? C'est disponible. Ouais.
Tu peux le tu peux le tu peux le tu peux
le télécharger.
C'est payant. Euh c'est payant le le
parce que en fait tu dois euh la
particularité d'un du d'un réseau
d'anonymisation, c'est que c'est pas
fourni par une entité centralisée.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas nous, la
société euh qui allons fournir euh ce
réseau dans lequel tu vas
discuter. Euh pour
pouvoir pour faire du chiffrement bout à
bout, c'est relativement facile. tu as
deux machines, tu as un logiciel de
chiffrement et tu fais tu fais un
message entre les deux. Mais pour créer
de l'anonymat euh c'est bien plus
particulier en fait. Tu dois avoir un
réseau
d'ordinateur euh à travers le monde.
Donc nous on a environ je crois qu'il y
a environ 500 ou 600 serveurs à travers
le monde qui vont en fait tous discuter
entre eux constamment.
Euh même si toi tu le tu tu utilises pas
le réseau, ils vont discuter entre eux
et euh ils vont euh ils vont générer du
bruit des fausses communications
constamment.
Et lorsque toi, lorsque nous deux, on va
se connecter sur ce réseau là pour pour
envoyer un message, on va en fait
envoyer un message à travers un du bruit
qui est généré par tout le monde. Et en
fait, on ce bruit le paquet que tu
envoies, la communication que tu envoies
n'est pas on peut pas la distinguer des
autres des autres communications. Ton
bruit il est modulé. Mon bruit il est
pas modulé justement. C'est en fait tout
le monde
enfin ça dépend de ce que tu veux dire
par modulé mais en fait tous les paquets
sont de la même taille. Comment on a
craqué ? On envoie tout le on voit tous
un message de la même taille euh avec le
même rythme euh à à travers le réseau.
Comment on a craqué Enigma ?
Comment on a craqué Enigma ? Euh bah
avec l'appareil de Turing. Donc il a
inventé l'informatique pour craquer
l'énigma. Qui était la porteuse ?
La
porteuse euh c'est-à-dire les courriers
finissaient par quoi ?
Ah ça je sais plus
ça. Bon
passons, changeons.
Est-ce que tu as eu des pressions de
certains gouvernements pour euh Pas
encore. Non, pas encore. Non. Ton équipe
est formée de combien de personnes ?
Est-ce que c'est des personnes sûres ?
Est-ce que tu es pas sûr qu'il y a pas
un développeur qui est financé par un
service étranger pour aller mettre des
petites choses dedans ? Tout possible,
c'est tout à fait possible. Mais tout le
développement est open source.
Euh on gère pas le réseau. Le gé le le
réseau, il est géré par une communauté
euh d'ailleurs qui est qui est qui est
payé pour ça euh qui a des intérêts
économiques en fait à faire tourner ces
réseaux-là. Euh l'équipe, elle est euh
euh tout le travail de l'équipe est
transparent, euh tout est open source
euh et ce qui fait que euh
on se donne les chances en fait euh au
maximum de de de réduire notre euh notre
surface d'attaque euh pour des
gouvernements ou d'autres qui auraient
intérêt à casser finalement le
la sécurité de notre système. Après,
c'est une course, c'està-dire que en
cryptographie ou en sécurité de réseau,
tu as toujours une course entre la
cryptographie et la cryptanalyse. Donc
l'attaque, la défense, elle est là
constamment. Donc nous
notre ce que ce que l'on doit faire,
c'est jouer ce jeu de l'attaque et la
défense constamment. Euh et donc on
s'attaque nous-même par exemple euh on a
avec notre propre équipe, on est
constamment en train de s'attaquer. On a
demandé à des auditeurs externes de
s'attaquer. On va faire des bug bounty
pour nous attaquer. Euh donc le le ce
combien les failles ? Euh il y a moyen.
Il y a pas encore le il y a pas encore
les tarifs sur les failles. C'est vrai ?
Non. Et si tu veux pâer du chasseur, il
faut mettre du gibier hein. Ah oui, on
en mettra mais pour l'instant on on a
pas encore commencé le le euh le
euh le pen test euh avec les bugs si tu
te coupe, je suis désolé. Euh si tu
découvres des failles, tu vas
communiquer. Nous, on les communique.
Oui. Ouais. Quels sont les points
faibles de ton système ? Les points
faibles du système aujourd'hui c'est la
vitesse, c'est lent. Et donc en terme
d'utilisation euh on a on a on a on a
fait une application qui ressemble à un
VPN. Donc tu peux utiliser comme un Ven
rapide, normal, mais si tu veux vraiment
utiliser la partie anonymisation euh là
c'est lent. Voilà. Et donc c'est la plus
grosse faille aujourd'hui. La plus
grosse est-ce que tu indiques aux gens
qui souhaiteraient se
renforcer qui est-ce que tu leur
indiques en fait des des mesures
d'hygiène informatique comme bah
installe pas notre super VPN sur un
milieu qui est pas sécurisé parce que il
y aura moyen de te remonter par
derrière. Est-ce que tu expliques ça aux
gens ? Tu leur dis pas "Venez chez nous,
vous serez blindé". Tu tu as une une
politique pédagogique avec eux ou pas ?
On a une politique pédagogique. On on
travaille surtout pour pour l'instant
comme c'est au début, on a on a
développé en fait un un
un un un écosystème où en fait on a on
va voilà recommander aux gens d'avoir
les bonnes mises à jour, de un certain
type de de comportement.
le l'outil en lui-même va prendre
beaucoup de choses. Il va faire il va il
va lui-même protéger une partie de la
communication, mais évidemment, il peut
pas protéger les comportements de la
personne, hein. Ça c'est un truc qui est
qui est très important. Euh mais euh
quand la personne va venir dans notre
communauté, il va être accueilli par des
gens qui généralement essaient de de
enfin euh montre des bonnes pratiques
pour minimiser les les les mauvais
comportements. Tu as décidé de
travailler avec une pointe de diamant
qui est pour nous une EDS pour son
sacrifice pour l'intérêt général
mondial. Hm hm. Qui est-elle ? Chelsea
Maning. Depuis combien de temps tu la
connais ? Écoute,
on avec l'équipe parce qu'on est
plusieurs à la connaître dans l'équipe,
hein. On la connaît depuis 2000 depuis
2020.
Euh elle travaille avec nous depuis
2022, je crois dans mes souvenirs. Euh
et euh euh elle nous a rejoint euh pour
nous aider dans la dans la dans la
recherche. Euh elle a elle a une
connaissance énorme de de ce que euh des
menaces en fait qui sont qui sont qui
sont possibles contre contre un système
comme le nôtre ou dans le monde du
numérique de manière générale. Rappelle
rappelle à notre communauté qui est-elle
? Et alors, Chelsea Manning, c'est un
ancien soldat de l'armée américaine qui
était analyste dans l'armée américaine
pendant la guerre en en la guerre en
Irak. Analyste CIA, analyste NSA,
analyste analiste militaire militaire.
Voilà. Euh donc euh et euh elle était
stationnée en Irak et c'est elle enfin
c'est elle qui a euh sorti en fait les
informations pour les transférer à
Wikileak à Julia Nassange. Euh et c'est
de là qu'on a l'image la plus connue qui
s'appelle Collatéral Murder euh qui est
cette image où un journaliste américain
se fait abattre par un hélicoptère. Euh
il y a pas que lui d'ailleurs. Il y a
pas que lui. Oui. Il y a aussi tous les
gens autour. Euh et cette cette
euh cette image a choqué en fait le
monde à et a ouvert en fait une une
nouvelle ère. C'était l'aire de
euh les États peuvent plus garder des
informations secrètes. C'était ça en
fait ce qui a vraiment euh c'était le
point de pivot. Si si s'il y a un point
de pivot entre les secrets d'état et les
États posts secrets d'état, c'est je
pense c'est je pense ce moment-là euh et
ça et d'ailleurs ça a aussi modifié la
manière dont les États aujourd'hui euh
gèrent ces gèrent ces secrets là. Et
puis on le voit on le voit dans dans la
manière dont la formation aujourd'hui
est mise à nu. Euh il y a beaucoup plus
de il y a il reste des secrets, mais il
y a quand même beaucoup plus de
transparence de manière générale. Euh et
les secrets d'état sont beaucoup plus
difficile à conserver. Ça a été vraiment
à ce point de pivot. Euh elle a euh elle
a passé plusieurs années de en prison
euh pour cela. Euh toutes toutes environ
7 ans en prison en isolement. Euh elle a
été pardonnée par Obama. Euh et puis
ensuite, elle rejoint euh Nî pour
travailler parce que elle a elle
réfléchissait à ces thématiques aussi
pendant qu'elle était en prison et elle
est très amie avec Harry Alpine qui est
le CEO de NIM et donc ils se sont nous a
rejoint à ce moment-là pour pour nous
aider. Combien tu gagnes ?
Si je suis de d'origine protestante, ça
se dit pas. On est en Suisse, ça se dit
pas. On n'est pas en Suisse aujourd'hui.
Je gagne je gagne suffisamment ma vie
pour être bien en Suisse mais ça me fait
pas de moi quelqu'un qui est euh euh qui
est qui qui a pas besoin de travailler.
Voilà, on va dire ça. Combien tu payes
Chelsea ?
Euh combien je paye Chelsea ? quelque
chose de très c'est
c'est elle est elle est à temps partiel
pour nous et elle elle gagne aussi
quelque chose qui est tout à fait dans
la dans la norme dans de dans la norme
de
[Musique]
de gens qualifiés qui bosseraient dans
la sécurité ou des choses comme ça.
150000 dollars l'année. Euh si tu veux
une si c'est une grande échelle, on
c'est vraiment on est dans ces échelles
là. Oui. Ouais. C'est pas c'est pas de
c'est pas des des sommes qui sont bien
au-delà que que cela.
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview. Euh tu nous as fait venir
ici. Euh on fait pas de la promotion de
ton produit. Il y a eu aucune
transaction financière entre toi et moi.
Ton profil m'intéressait énormément. Un
Suisse, sécurité informatique,
protection des données, protection de la
vie privée, engagé dans le parti
pirate. Est-ce que tu as trois livres ?
Est-ce que tu veux aborder un autre
sujet d'ailleurs ? Est-ce que il y a un
truc qui vraiment te touche et que tu
souhaiterais propager au sein de la
communauté française ? Ouais. Euh j'ai
un sujet qui me qui me qui me touche,
c'est de revenir sur la notion de
données. Euh la de données personnelles
qui est vraiment le cœur de ce que de ce
que l'on ce que l'on fait. Euh et en
fait, il y a aussi une lecture
géopolitique à cette donnée. Enfin, moi
j'ai cette lecture géopolitique et et la
cryptographie justement et le droit à
l'intégrité numérique tel que je les je
les je les mélange tous les deux euh me
permettent de voir me permettre
d'analyser ça. Ça c'est ma proposition.
En fait, le monde est divisé aujourd'hui
en deux grandes zones d'influence au
niveau de la donnée. Tu as le monde
américain, on va dire, je schématise,
hein, le monde américain de la silicone
vanille. Silicone vallée, la donnée,
c'est un objet, une commodité. Euh c'est
le pétrole du 21e siècle. on peut
l'extraire, on peut en on peut
transformer et on peut le réinjecter et
manipuler les gens, c'est pas un
problème. De l'autre côté, il y a le
monde
sinorusse où le la donnée est un est un
est un bien commun. Ça appartient en
fait à la société et le responsable
ultime de cela, c'est l'État.
Alors l'État chinois ou les oligarques
russes dont le but est de don qui
peuvent extraire en fait ces donnéeslà
pour le bonheur populaire en Chine et
puis pour d'autres raisons en Russie.
Mais mais c'est pas quelque chose qui
appartient aux entreprises qui
collectent ces données là. À la fin,
c'est l'État qui qui dirige. Les
affaires Alibaba nous montrent que dès
que la la société devient trop grosse,
l'État reprend le contrôle. Ah bah
Jacques il a pris cher hein. Il a très
il a pris il a pris très cher. Et en
fait ces deux modèles-là travaillent
ensemble euh ils sont tous les deux basé
sur la captation de données et sur le
retour des données à travers les
algorithmes pour manipuler les gens. Euh
et en fait euh aujourd'hui en Europe, on
essaie de faire pareil.
On essaie de faire pareil et toute la
politique de industriel de de de Macron
ou d'autres leaders en Europe, c'est de
développer des géants du numérique
européen qui vont faire pareil. Mais on
a cette retenue en Europe de dire "Oui,
mais on veut
respecter certains droits, tout ça."
Donc on se met des limites et on narrive
pas à créer une industrie qui soit aussi
performante et on est complètement
dépendant. tous nos systèmes, tout en
fait ce qu'il faut voir c'est que toutes
nos systèmes de gouvernance euh de
d'école de business, tout est tout est
en utilisant des systèmes à la fois
américains et chinois.
nos données sont constamment capté par
ces deux ces deux zones
géopolitiques. Et donc moi mon ma
proposition en fait c'est de dire au
lieu d'essayer de faire pareil, faisons
l'opposé, créons un monde où en fait on
collecte pas de données où en fait
l'État vient pas collecter de données.
Vient les entreprises ont pas besoin de
collecter le train enfin la société de
train n'a pas besoin de connaître ton
nom pour te mettre d'un point A à un
point B. Et pourtant
aujourd'hui euh euh les sociétés de
train c'est les plus gros c'est c'est
des c'est des systèmes, ils ont ils
connaissent le nom de tout le monde qui
circule sur leur sur dans leur train.
Chaque fois que tu prends un abonnement
à ticket, il faut d'identité, il faut un
nom. Euh il protège peut-être le réseau
contre des attaques
terroristes. Tu vas en Ukraine et tu
regardes comment il protège le le réseau
de train. Je l'ai vu, j'ai pris le train
de Hougorod à Kief. Ben tu as des
soldats à chaque pont qui vérifient que
personne vient poser une bombe. Ça
marche très bien. A pas besoin de
connaître ton nom pour ça. Tu vois euh
il y a une manière de de de faire alors
c'est pas les mêmes euh c'est pas les
mêmes risques, on est d'accord. Mais ce
que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'en
fait, on peut créer un monde euh où euh
le le défaut, le le l'approche par
défaut, c'est celle de la non captation
de données euh en investissant euh dans
euh la dans la cryptographie. Et ça va
nous permettre à ce moment-là de
respecter les droits humains, de
respecter l'intégrité de la personne. Si
on collecte pas les données, on peut ne
on on va pas on va pas agresser une
personne si on n pas ces donnéeslà. Et
en même temps, ça a une implication
géopolitique, c'est-à-dire qu'à partir
du moment où tu as tout un continent qui
disparaît de la capacité de captation
des autres continents, et ben c'est une
vraie souveraineté numérique qu'on peut
construire. Moins d'influence
extérieure, moins ingérence. Exactement.
Et sortir des algorithmes qui sont pas
les nôtres, c'est les algorithmes
chinois, les algorithmes américains et
qui sur lequel on se bat aujourd'hui.
Tu es vraiment utopiste ? Je suis
vraiment utopiste. Ouais. Qu'est-ce qui
te ferait changer d'avis ?
Euh je vais te raconter une histoire un
peu drôle, c'est euh il y a un petit
musée à à Nechâtel qui est un musée
d'histoire et Nechel c'est une ville
suisse qui a vécu la Révolution
française. Euh euh et il y a deux
salles. Il y a deux salles. Euh il y a
enfin il y a plusieurs salles mais à un
moment donné il y a deux salles. Il y a
une salle sur les lumières. Voilà. Et
puis Jean-Jacques Rousseau passait à
passait à Nechel, il avait son éditeur.
Dans mon village, il y
a euh Jean-Paul Mara qui est né dans mon
village. Enfin, c'est une ville très
c'est c'est une région très euh très
riche en histoire révolutionnaire
française. Et donc voilà, il y a il y a
une une salle qui montre les lumières et
et tout ce que les gens ont fait de beau
et de bien à Nechatel. tu passes la
salle d'après et puis tu vois euh
l'époque de la
réforme euh où tout le monde est habillé
en noir, où en fait on exécute tout le
monde. Voilà. Et puis en fait quand tu
regardes les les quand tu regardes les
en fait les dates, tu te rends compte
que les dates se superposent.
En fait euh ces phénomènesl ils se sont
passés en même temps. C'est que dans la
transformation de la société de l'âge
féodal à l'âge industriel qui était la
révolution française, en fait tu avais
le pire et le meilleur qui se passait en
même temps. Les la transformation là,
c'est pas d'abord le monde qui va
vraiment dans le dans dans la merde et
puis après il y a une utopie qui se crée
et tout est beau et c'est l'époque
industrielle. les deux les deux les
idées enfin les trucs horribles et les
trucs bien se passent en même temps en
fait. Et je pense
que je pense que c'est ce qu'on va vivre
aussi. On va avoir à la fois de des
choses horribles, on va voir à la fois
des choses d'espoir qui vont euh qui
vont se faire. Et moi, je préfère
travailler sur les euh les points
d'espoir, les points utopiques. Il faut
euh semer les graines et semer les
graines de logique pour en fait
permettre dans le futur à peut-être mes
enfants euh de d'expérimenter euh
d'expérimenter dans des nouveaux
systèmes de gouvernance et de d'avoir
des voilà des tentatives de nouvelles
sociétés. Euh mais euh je suis conscient
que les deux euh les deux les deux
mondes vont se vont coexister en fait.
Tu vois qu'est-ce qui a déclenché la
Révolution française ?
Déclenché vraiment déclenché. Tu veux
dire la Qu'est-ce qui a permis ce terau
fertile ? Ah euh ça alors moi j'ai une
j'ai une j'ai un élément de réponse,
c'est le taux d'alphabétisation.
Il est passé de 10 % en 1700 à 20 % en
1800 ou enfin en 1789.
Et si je te dis,
le le changement climatique, enfin le le
le courant qui perturbe le climat là. Si
je te dis Eligho qui a créé de la
flotte, des mauvaises récoltes, la faim,
des gens qui en avaient marre, c'est une
conjonction de tout ça. C'est une
conjonction. C'est-à-dire que le
le la fin, c'est le c'est toujours
l'effet déclencheur, c'est-à-dire c'est
ce qui fait passer euh une c'est ce qui
déclenche une révolte violente. Ça s'est
passé en Tunisie, ça s'est passé à la
Révolution française. Voilà. Mais le le
terro il est là et le terro il est un
changement profond dans la société. Euh
et pour moi en 1789, c'était
alphabétisation, nouvelle technologie.
Il y avait plein de choses qui se sont
passées au 18e siècle euh où la
l'apprissement de l'ancien régime par
rapport à l'enrichissement d'une de des
des bourgeois. Tout ça fait met en place
un ter qui euh qui qui a besoin d'un
déclencheur. Le déclencheur, c'est euh
la fin qui euh euh qui un jour euh fait
que les pauvres gens, le le loopen
prolétariat va euh va aller euh prendre
les armes pour euh
euh parce qu'il est pas content tout
simplement et qui sera sûrement et qui
est sûrement manipulé par les bourgeois
à l'époque et qui sera manipulé par un
algorithme aujourd'hui.
Ta boîte, elle est financée par qui ?
Vous êtes vous avez commencé dans une
cave ? Est-ce qu'il y a des États qui
ont mis du pognon dedans ? Est-ce que un
état peut prendre le contrôle de ta
boîte ? Alors, on a été financé un tout
petit peu par la recherche
européenne. Euh l'Union européenne a mis
des un petit peu d'argent, pas
grand-chose, mais dans les
200000 dans les 200000 €.
Euh ensuite, on a été financé par des
investisseurs à travers le monde. Euh ça
va de
Andreenorovitz euh à des plateformes de
de bourses chinoises comme
euh euh Wobi, c'est des des bourses de
cryptomonnaie.
euh des investisseurs étranges, des
investisseurs du monde entier en fait
euh qui ont préacheté nos services.
Combien ? Euh eux, ils ont investi à peu
près euh 20 millions et ensuite on a
fait une vente publique. Donc c'est des
petits c'est des petits porteurs euh qui
ont participé à une vente publique qui a
eu lieu en 2022 et pour environ 30
millions. Donc on a levé environ 50
millions euh pour développer développer
cela. Euh est-ce que un état peut euh
prendre le contrôle ? Euh en fait le le
mécanisme de fonctionnement euh c'est
que le le réseau en fait euh c'est un
réseau qui est rémunéré et dans lequel
les participants doivent acheter leur
place d'une certaine manière. Et euh et
pour acheter sa place, il faut acheter
un un jeton qui s'appelle le jeton NIM
et le mettre dans les dans et le et le
et le le mettre dans des machines. Euh
si tu veux aujourd'hui attaquer, prendre
le contrôle de du réseau, il faut non
seulement avoir plein de machines, mais
il faut aussi récupérer tous les jetons
sur le marché. Et ce qui fait que tu
aurais un phénomène un peu un peu
particulier, c'est que bah le prix va
augmenter automatiquement. Donc racheter
en fait un le le réseau NIM, ça serait
visible parce que ça voudrait ça
prendrait ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait aussi qu'un l'attaquant ou
l'État aille acheter les jetons à tous
ceux qui en ont. Donc il y en a pour
combien ? Et il y en a il y a pour euh
il y en a aujourd'hui pour environ euh
200 millions euh de valeurs euh de jeton
en dollars.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à ma communauté ?
Euh
alors, j'en ai
trois. Le premier c'est la petite
poussette de Michel Ser.
Euh ça explique finalement ce changement
de génération euh fondamental qui s'est
passé.
Euh la petite poussette, c'est elle elle
a elle s'appelle la petite poussette
parce que elle tape avec les pouces sur
sur l'écran et Michel Ser était pour moi
un des plus grands philosophes de du
numérique malgré son âge très avancé.
Euh ça c'est un euh le deuxième euh le
l'individu souverain. Alors je sais plus
le le nom de l'auteur, l'individu
souverain, c'est une explication. Il
commence pas par Eric. Euh non,
c'est Sovereign Individual en anglais
euh et qui est un livre qu'il faut lire
avec beaucoup de de critiques, mais qui
montre la la transformation de la
société
euh de
l'âge féodal vers industriel et
industriel vers numérique et que les
mouvements, les types de changements
fondamental fondamentaux qui sont en
train de se passer se se répète en fait
dans l'histoire et notamment la thèse de
ce livre, c'est de dire que le le le la
monopole de la violence en fait à chaque
è se transforme et et ce qui s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé entre l'époque
féodale et aujourd'hui et l'époque
industrielle et ce qui va se passer
aussi avec l'époque numérique euh la
cryptographie va être une nouvelle est
une nouvelle arme en fait pour pour
cela. l'individu souverain James Dell
Davidson et Lord Williams Resmoke.
Voilà. Et puis euh le 3è euh un
révolutionnaire qui me qui m'inspire
beaucoup
euh c'est Abdouah Shalan.
Abdouah qui est actuellement en prison
en Turquie et il a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle le le démoc le confédéralisme
démocratique qui lui est disponible
gratuitement et qui explique comment
justement en au Kurdistan syrien au
milieu de au milieu du désert et entouré
de de l'État islamique et
d'autres d'autres dangers il créent un
une société sans frontière décentralisée
euh où ce principe de
subsidiarité est fait depuis le bas. Euh
et en fait, il inspire beaucoup
aujourd'hui les il inspire beaucoup les
les
milieux
technologiques qui travaillent sur les
technologies de la
décentralisation et il est en train de
devenir un des influenceurs les
plus un des pense porseurs les plus
influents dans ce dans ce domaineel. Tu
te rappelles de l'affaire Tru Crypt ?
Bien sûr. Et puis à la suite verra
Crypt. Ouais. Euh troupe
Crypt le gars a disparu du jour au
lendemain. Euh et ensuite il est revenu,
il a mis un petit message le développeur
voilà, il a mis un petit message en
disant "N'utilisez pas mon truc parce
que il a pas dit comme ça. Il a pas dit
comme ça." Mais bon, il a dit en gros
tout le monde a compris que il fallait
plus utiliser son système parce que
c'était compromis. Euh tu feras la même
chose si ça t'arrive.
Tu sais jamais comment euh tu sais
jamais ce qui va se passer en fait au
moment où ça se passe. Mais ce qu'on a
mis en place, c'est qu'on c'est qu'on on
se met les conditions pour que si jamais
euh
euh quelque chose comme ça se passe, ce
soit visible directement. C'est-à-dire
que c'est c'est soit à travers voilà, il
y a un dispositif de main du mort.
Ouais. Verrip, tu veux remettre un petit
mot ? Verrip, tu veux continuer ? Non.
et puis Veracrip, ben c'était
intéressant parce qu'après effectivement
la communauté a
repris est revenu sur le sur une version
d'avant, a retravailler la chose et puis
a fait continuer à vivre le logiciel que
bah j'utilise aussi encore Veracrypt, ça
marche bien. Euh euh mais c'était
vraiment oui, c'était un moment assez
particulier dans l'histoire de
l'informatique et peu connu des des gens
mais qui touche parce
que euh ça touche à cette relation entre
le entre ça touche cette relation la
pression que peuvent avoir les gens qui
qui développent ce genre de d'outil. Euh
et en fait tout ça, ce sont des des
leçons que on apprend euh de faire tout
seul en outil dans un coin. C'était le
gars de de Truc Crypt, il était tout
seul dans un coin, la pression a été
trop forte pour lui et puis il a pas euh
il a pas su la la gérer ou il a pas pu
la gérer, je sais pas. Euh nous ce qu'on
a fait, c'est qu'on a un projet qui est
totalement transparent.
Le code source, il est open. Euh, on
peut le on peut le on peut on peut nous
voir, on peut nous suivre depuis un
certain temps. Tout
est on s'est on s'est doxé soi-même
constamment et ce qui fait que euh et
puis on est des personnages tous dans
l'équipe de dirigeant de dirigeants qui
sont tous des personnages un peu
particuliers.
Euh moi, j'ai mon utopie. Voilà, on peut
on peut essayer de venir
[Musique]
me si on me demande de de mettre une
bague d'or dans le système, je pourrais
juste pas le faire en fait. C'est ça en
fait. Si je kidnappe tes
enfants, tu trouveras les moyens. C'est
une blague mauvaise. Tu connaissais
Syerview ? Tu avais regardé quoi de chez
nous ? Euh, j'avais regardé l'émission
avec euh Sébastien Guspiou et Alexandre
Sachenko. Voilà, je leur fais coucou. On
était encore la semaine dernière
ensemble. Euh j'ai vu celle de j'en ai
vu plusieurs plein. J'ai vu celle avec
euh un autre ami qui s'appelle Olivier
Laurellie Bluetootouf. Euh euh puis j'en
avais vu euh quand même un un paquet
d'autres. Ouais. Tu as regardé celle
avec le papa d'Assange ? Euh non, je
l'ai pas regardé avec le papa d'Asse.
Non. Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable sur internet. sur les
internets. sur les
internets.
Euh ne pensez ne croyez ne croyez plus à
rien sur internet.
C'est tout. C'est tout. Ne croyez plus à
rien sur internet. Alexis Rousell.
Merci.
[Musique]